so john cena really stepped in it
apparently he was doing an interview and
he referred to taiwan as a country
which he probably knows almost nothing
about and this triggered a major
backlash in china
you see wwe nba a bunch of american
companies have been expanding into china
making tons of money and so they're very
concerned about losing that money we saw
this with the nba with lebron with steve
kerr with mark cuban
now it's wwe so so john cena puts out
this very weird video where he's like
trying to speak mandarin apologizing
saying he just didn't know
you know that taiwan is not a country
the interesting thing about this is that
well to americans taiwan is and there's
serious questions about the lengths
americans are willing to go to do
something about china and what it could
ultimately lead to and there's
fear of war and something called
thucydides trap which we reference
a lot actually which means if you're not
familiar as a rising power comes to
displace the reigning economic power war
breaks out
and that's something we we really don't
want we got a couple other stories you
know rand paul is calling republicans to
leave twitter
because these lefty personalities these
democrats
have been mocking and encouraging
essentially
these attacks by praising the guy who
attacked him you know caused very
serious injuries to rand paul
and so we're going to get into this also
we've got talk about you know israel
obviously and we're being joined
by scott horton of antiwar.com
very happy to be here thank you for
having me you want just a real quick
introduction
who you are what you do sure i'm the
editorial director of antiwar.com
i'm the director of the libertarian
institute which is me and sheldon
richmond
and pete quinones and kyle anzalone and
a bunch of great writers and podcasters
over there
and um i host the scott horton show
i've got 5 500 interviews going back to
2003 on scotthorton.org
and i host anti-war radio on sunday
mornings on kpfk
in los angeles 90.7 fm and i wrote two
books
fool's errand time to end the war in
afghanistan and then the brand new one
out this year is enough already
time to end the war on terrorism right
on man so we're going to talk about all
this stuff and uh we got ian yes
ian crossland up in here uh at
iancrossland.net
and at ian crosson on social media great
to see you scott and i am
in the corner pushing buttons i'm really
excited for this conversation i'm ready
to get educated about foreign policy
we're gonna have a really great i think
i think we got a bunch of news to go
through but there'll be a really great
philosophical discussion about war and
conflict and all that stuff which i
think would be really really interesting
but before we get started my friends we
have an awesome sponsor we have biotrust
multi ageless collagen angel's
multi-collagen i got it backwards
go to strongerbonesandlife.com the link
is
in the description below and you can
secure your supply of ageless
multi-collagen
up to 51 off while supplies
last you may be asking me why do i need
collagen i know how old you are
i do because we have demographic and
analytics in youtube
and i know most of you are the same age
as me and so uh you know earlier
uh scott you were skating on the ramps
you did you did a nice little back 50 on
that quarter pipe
and uh well we're just a bunch of old
men trying to skate so if you want to
take your joints
and your health seriously the health of
your joints your skin your bones
you got to make sure you're getting your
collagen and so this is what you get
biotrust
multi ageless multi-collagen it's
unflavored it never clumps ian puts it
in his
my coffee right now it's good stuff it's
good stuff we make smoothies we throw it
in
and the cats can't get enough of it like
whenever the cats get these bags they
try eating it
so you got to keep it away from the cats
but they know it's good or put it in
their food maybe yeah
oh i don't know i'm not going to
recommend a doctor but but no but in all
seriousness you know we've got a bunch
of skate ramps and i do take this very
seriously so it's good for your skin
if you are a lovely lady who's listening
and you want your skin to be supple and
youthful that's what you want to buy
so go to strongerbonesnlife.com they say
51
off we got some important things you
need to know you get a 60 day money back
guarantee
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources
for every order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date
biotrust has provided over 4.4 million
meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million years
5 million meals this year not 5 million
years
it is a non-gmo and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners and free
of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbst
no odor or taste there's no clumping
unlike other collagen supplements
free shipping on every order this is the
coolest part you get free vip
life free vip live health and fitness
coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for
life with every order plus you get the
free
new e-report the 14 foods for amazing
skin with every order
i know you guys are a similar age to me
so take your health seriously man
it's not worth it to to ignore at this
like especially this time in my life i'm
like
not 19 anymore i'm not going to be
jumping off buildings i got to make sure
i'm actually having like a healthy diet
so go to strongerbonesnlife.com special
thank you to biotrust and don't forget
check out timcast.com become a member we
will have an exclusive members only
segment
after the show where we say the things
youtube doesn't let us and we swear a
whole lot so if you're interested in
seeing something like that
go to timcast.com support our work and
in actuality we're trying to build the
site because
every membership we get from you guys is
money that goes towards expanding
we're looking to hire journalists we're
looking to bring in more talent do more
shows
we got the paranormal show we've got
this political show that's uh
we're planning on doing a bunch of it's
about like the collapse of
of you know political institutions and
civil wars and things like that so
please consider becoming a member to
help support that expansion let's jump
into this first
story and it's silly and it's stupid
it's also kind of creepy
from the south china morning post wwe
superstar
john cena is very sorry to chinese fans
for referring to taiwan as a country
in fast and furious nine promotional
interview
isn't this there's a ninth fast and the
furious move you guys it's the
it's i've long said the ffcu the best
cinematic universe
anyway john cena said on taiwanese tv
that it would be the first country to
watch the film
american quickly the american quickly
backtracked on weibo
saying he made one mistake after doing a
lot of interviews
it's it's it's kind of creepy he said hi
china i'm john cena i'm in the middle of
a fast and furious nine promotions
i'm doing a lot of interviews i made a
mistake in one of my interviews everyone
was asking me if i could use
chinese staff gave me a lot of
information so there was a lot of
interviews and information
said cena who started learning mandarin
to help his wrestling promotion
integration in china
he has since gone viral many times for
his enthusiastic mandarin speaking
abilities
i respect him for trying absolutely i
made one mistake
i have to say something very very
important now i love and respect china
and chinese people
i'm very very sorry about my mistake i
apologize i apologize i'm very sorry
you must understand that i really love
really respect
china and the chinese people my
apologies see you
all i heard was please keep giving me
money please keep giving me money i
don't want to lose money
there are more than 5 000 comments on
cena's weibo apology quote
please say in chinese that taiwan is
part of china
otherwise we won't accept it wrote one
weibo user
the weibo user the message has over 3
200 likes
then you should say taiwan is china's
wrote another user
what you have said in the video is
nonsense you can't take benefits from
china
but in the meantime do things to harm
china's interests
others supported cena with one person
writing i like you i think you truly
love china
don't talk carelessly again about
china's territory and sovereignty
so of course it's it's it's a silly
story in a lot of ways
i'm not sure how how much it really
matters but it's a grain of sand and a
bigger heap of
many you know companies sports
we had uh the nba you couldn't put free
hong kong on a jersey
they wouldn't allow they would say error
can't you you'd make a custom jersey and
try to put free hong kong no can't do it
we've seen in many like uh esports
people have said free hong kong
out and so it's it's curious you know we
had cassandra fairbanks on and she made
really good points about
not wanting to go to war with china
under any circumstances even the things
we're seeing that are bad
and there's some deep philosophical
philosophical questions here the the big
thing i take issue with
with things like john cena being
deferential to china is that there's
clearly american interests
is he more interested in making money by
expanding his business into
china which means supporting chinese
interests against american interests
there's i don't think there's a way to
to play both sides on this one right in
america
we as a country we respect taiwan as a
country we do so you
you know people our rights are allowed
to have their own opinions john cena
wants to be
i guess he wants to be in line with
china because he's got money to be made
there
and so what ends up happening is china
doesn't tolerate
the free speech in the same way the u.s
does john cena can say this what's the
worst can happen we're going to insult
him
maybe if he says something truly agrees
we'll boycott him in china
he has to come out and apologize in the
us he wouldn't do it so that means so
long as they're more
authoritarian in their speech or i
should say
more collectivist than
they're going to keep winning a lot of
these corporate battles which means a
lot more resources will flow towards
china away from the us
and that will incentivize the political
class to continue extracting resources
through
sending our manufacturing and things
like that but in terms of the bigger the
broader point
which is thucydides trap you're probably
familiar with this yeah
uh scott which is are we heading towards
war with china because of their economic
expansion
i'm curious just is you know your
thoughts i guess is it a good thing or a
bad thing
my personal opinion i think it's really
bad because uh
i think a lot of what we're seeing with
these corporations going to china is bad
because i'm concerned about
individualism
liberty and what happens to the world if
china becomes a superpower that
supplants the us and starts doing what
the us is doing but with
chinese communist authoritarianism
instead of
classical liberalism i understand from a
historical perspective not from the
current american perspective but the
very least we have a constitution right
sure so i'm curious what do you think
well listen i mean i think
you're on to something that it's a real
worry when american
you know media characters and companies
are so heavily invested in china are so
heavily dependent
on uh on chinese money that then
you know it undermines american values
like free speech and things like you're
talking about there
we saw this with and you know we're
at the humorous stage of this right it
could get a lot worse you know john cena
and some basketball players and stuff
right the one that i thought was really
funny
was when they remade red dawn yeah
i'm an 80s kid so i love the original
red dawn fact i just watched it recently
and it's
just hilarious and wonderful um but i've
watched the remake of it and it's just
an absolute catastrophe and the movie
it was i guess it came out like pretty
near after the 08 crash
and so the idea was that the american
government clearly after george w bush
was so irresponsible right that and had
had run america in the ground so badly
that then the chinese were going to take
the advantage and conquer north america
which is about as easily as the russians
doing it back in the 80s by the way but
it was north korea wasn't it yeah well
they switched it
right so this is what happened when they
filmed the movie they had
um i remember there's a lady named karen
decoster that wrote for lou rockwell.com
that was talking about how they were
filming the movie in
chicago and they had big red chinese
flags hanging down
and all these things she's like oh
they're remaking red dawn and it's china
this time
but then by the time the movie came out
it wasn't china anymore now it's north
korea
and so if you watch it then like the
beginning of the movie is like a 10
minute or like a little five minute news
montage
to try to explain the story of how north
korea ended up conquering all of
asia and then came across the pacific
ocean for us next
and it's just the most ridiculous thing
and and the movie was just terrible
anyway it had no redeeming quality
anyway but it was just the fact that
they had to change it from
something that was mildly plausible
right
like china is they gotta sell the movie
yeah they have to sell a movie in china
so they had to change it and so i think
that could be a problem but i think look
overall the more investment that we have
in china and the more investment that
they have
here the better off we all are and the
safer we are from violent conflict
that's the
famous quote from frederick bastiat
where goods do not cross borders
soldiers will and so we're better off if
you remember when china shot down the
spy plane in 2001
and colin powell made peace real quick
said sorry
and then i forgot if they got the plane
back or not
but but they resolved it really quickly
and that was because
of wall street and and the amount of
investments that they have in china
dictated that we keep things cool but
now
there's a there's another major
competing interest in corporate america
besides
you know walmart and all those guys and
that is
the ship builders and the long-range
bomb
man bomber manufacturers and they have a
major
interest in pursuing cold war with china
and ratcheting these things up right so
we have in a way is a war
between big business factions in america
those who want to import and sell cheap
crap
or whatever it is versus those who want
to sell weapons to the captive market
that is the pentagon
and those are huge big ticket items when
you're talking about the next generation
long-range bomber billion dollars
no i think i think i think it is true
right trade lines make it harder for
there to be war
the problem is everybody thought
that with with opening up trade to china
they would start to adopt more of
of our values and it seems like that's
not happening they're actually
the chinese communist party is still
very much ideological
ideologically driven and in control of
most of these companies
and it seems like it's actually just
resulting in the extraction of american
manufacturing
wealthy elites have found a path towards
extracting
the labor from the u.s making money by
shipping things overseas
and there's there is very much that idea
i think you know
we saw this with a lot of the
establishment democrats 10 years ago
the trans-pacific partnership this idea
like oh okay let's give them a bunch of
stuff with this trade deal
it'll make it harder for there to be war
but the tpp was was
was nightmarish trump was like i got to
shut this down there was you know ian
often uh often brings it up that the
corporations and foreign countries could
then sue americans yeah the investor
state dispute settlement clause
in the tpp said that if we wanted to not
buy malaysian oil for some reason they
could sue us for discrimination and then
the taxpayer would have to fund this the
lawsuit what ends up happening is
while it may be true or that in many
circumstances
you'll get some crossover where people
might actually come together that means
we have to start adopting
chinese ideological i should say the
communist party's ideological values
well it doesn't mean that right i mean
for example
these basketball stars or whoever could
go a lot more broke
crossing the american people and selling
out our values of free speech
than pleasing the chinese right i mean
is john cena going to sacrifice his
american audience for a chinese one
or he wants to have it both ways but
this is this is the issue that i was
that i was mentioning that the
ramifications from
the american audience who aren't paying
attention to politics is that they're
going to shrug and say i don't care
whereas the chinese audience is very
much heavily invested
and very very you know pro-china so john
cena could come out and say
you know look it's it's it's where's the
most damaged
if he says taiwan is a country then he
loses tons of money in china
if he says taiwan is not a country then
nothing's going to happen to the united
states
so he defers to china you that's a grain
of sand you you do that over and over
again eventually you have this heat
where
you look at the companies that want to
be in in china google for instance
in order for a company to operate in
china they have to have a chinese
communist party member in that company
in that office in the country
so now google starts you know you start
seeing protest in the u.s
when google was developing a chinese
censored search engine
right people protested google claims
shut it down i guess
i'm not sure we have to have the experts
back on but there's report rumors that
google just decided to just give in and
start doing what they wanted
the american people too many of them
don't care and don't pay attention
and so because of that these companies
are like what's our risk
you can piss off americans but americans
don't pay attention so they probably
won't do anything anyway
but these other countries that are much
more invested in their country will get
mad so
let's just make sure we're keeping them
happy and then over a long enough period
of time it seems like we're becoming too
different to china because
our business interests are yeah but then
again look at all the backlash against
the nba stars
who uh you know said everybody be quiet
about hong kong or whatever a couple
years ago and
i don't know exactly the backlash
against cena but there's there's a
substantial one about this
right he's be clowning himself selling
out
selling out you know what he obviously
thought
as you just said all i hear is money
money money
right which by the way you know the
situation with taiwan is very
complicated
after the civil war the nationalists
escaped to taiwan
and then the americans sailed the the
seventh fleet in there i guess
and prevented mao's forces from
following them and conquering them
and then from 1949 through like 74
america only recognized taiwan as the
official legitimate government of china
even though they really only ruled this
tiny island and all of mainland
mainland china was had been under the
rule of the maoists for by that time
like 30-something years
and so nixon and kissinger in a move
that was really
made to one screw the soviet union and
two
kind of ameliorate from the fact that he
was pulling us out of vietnam
by saying well don't worry about the
domino effect because we made friends
with the mouse
so now that we're friends with china it
doesn't matter so much that we're losing
in vietnam
and so they recognize china
as you know the the communist government
in beijing as the official government of
china which was only reasonable
but then they adopted this policy of
strategic ambiguity
when it comes to the fate of taiwan and
so america
has no treaty with taiwan and we're not
sworn to protect them
but since nixon and various presidents
say this in different ways trump almost
accidentally changed the doctrine
in the way that he stated it but then
his state department walked it back
but essentially the position is that
there is one china and the government in
beijing
is the official government of all of
china including taiwan
but that america will always oppose the
reunification by force
but then in what way will we oppose it
will we sell f-16s
to taiwan if so how many and then if
that doesn't work
then what and this is the real crisis
now is let's say
that the chinese decide that we're
taking back taiwan next year
what's america going to do about it joe
biden well
what's any american president what's
your favorite american president going
to do about it he's going to get into a
nuclear war he's going to lose tokyo
and honolulu and los angeles in exchange
for taipei
and what do we get out of that nothing
and what do we really care
if the chinese conquer taiwan what
difference does that make to you or me
at all other than we're against war we
don't want to see anybody violently
killed well
but in terms of the american people's
national interest
there's not one town much less major
city we should be willing to trade
for taipei and by the way if we got into
a nuclear war with china over taiwan
they'd get taiwan at the end of the day
anyway we'd end up losing la in san
francisco
and getting nothing out of it in
exchange al already like in my mind i
can see
like the the the path of like the
conflict
and the arguments over for and against
that i hear so often from
i wouldn't necessarily say the pro-war
people but the
like and i don't think well there's
probably people say they're pro-war for
sure but most people try to pass it off
like
it's war essentialism like i wish we
didn't have to have it right we do
well see this is what you're talking
about with the i always forget how to
pronounce it the
greek trap there though thucydides
trapped the acidities trapped through
acidities
through cities like i never said he was
a guy so but here's the guy
the thing of it is that if america would
just renounce our world empire
which we're not supposed to have in the
first place that's right then it
wouldn't matter that china is the rising
power the reason this is a trap
is because america has declared that the
entire pacific ocean is an american lake
and we won't settle for only 99 percent
all of it belongs to us
or will go to war over the idea but
that's not legitimate
so if china becomes again the dominant
power in east asia
as it's always been for thousands of
years
then we have to go to war against that
or we have to recognize
that this is the middle part of north
america
and that sounds to me like japan and
korea and vietnam's problem
not mine yeah i mean if you look back at
the the
i would assume a lot of the intent of
the founding fathers was not to do any
of this
but at a certain they warned us
explicitly against
foreign engagement like this in
entangling alliances
whether you know with european powers or
anyone else you could imagine
and it changed foreign intervention all
altogether
world war one i think it changed
everything that's right all of a sudden
yeah all of a sudden now it was uh
every war was our responsibility became
the world police so so but let's get a
little philosophical i suppose
if so we've had different experts you
know on talking about china
sure if if biden can't defend taiwan
then we can already see china's
expansion the claims of the south china
sea the attacking of the vietnamese
fishing vessels
they'll just expand and exert influence
and take over and so the fear is
what happens if the u.s does nothing do
we eventually have a china
that does what the u.s does and do you
want to think so
i don't think so but look at that what i
mean they would be insane
to look at what america's done for the
last 20 30 years and say let's replicate
that
we'll build 800 bases all around the
world and then we'll kill two million
iraqis and syrians and yemenis and then
we'll blow our own brains out and our
civilization will collapse
why would they do that could they
possibly be as dumb as the bushes and
the clintons they're building their
bases on nuclear submarines so they're
mobile and underwater they are expanding
the
tolls but but i will say this i do think
there is a certain efficiency
in the chinese communist party's
authoritarianism i'm not saying it's a
good thing i'm saying that
you rule with an iron fist they dictate
and they have a plan for what they're
going to do whereas in the u.s
we have regime change every four years
almost like one guy wants to go blow up
this country george
george w is mad about you know saddam
and his dad's fight so he wants to bring
it back
then obama's like i guess there's money
we made so joe biden gets his brother
some contract deals in iraq
when you look at what's happening in the
u.s it's the extraction of value for
personal gain
yeah and it leads us i look at what what
the authoritarian you know the chinese
communist party what they do is it's
rigid
it's constructed it's control there's a
plan there they they're very rigid
and i look at the us and it's chaotic
exploitation
by the elites they don't care about you
they don't care about us but you really
think the chinese plan is world empire
rather than just short
their own area i don't know it looks
like a desperately poor country with
millions of of hungry people but look at
what they've been doing in africa
south america that what was it the belt
and road initiative
that's all men with briefcases right
that's not militarism
so it's i mean they have a tiny little
military base in djibouti
right otherwise they traipse across
africa we got special operations forces
in right more than half the countries in
africa they've got guys with briefcases
doing capital investments which is
interesting
because it's a chinese communist party
using capitalism using capitalist
enterprise to gain control
they're buying up tons of our land so my
fear is
i i would not want to live the way
people in hong kong are currently
you know with all the changes and the
people being arrested and in mainland
china
i like being able to tell you know i
don't care who the president is to you
know to eff or whatever
but uh they've all there's been direct
economic competition between china and
the us
i don't necessarily think warfare needs
to always be hot
with guns and so what happens when
yes through economic exploitation we end
up
deferential to the chinese communist
party i'm not i'm not in any way
advocating for what the us's
stupid plans with sending guys with guns
all over the place because you can
clearly see that china using investment
is doing way better in many ways we are
wasting time and money because we have
corporations we have big
military industrial you know companies
that just want to
expand and make more even when when
congress says or even when the army's
like we don't need any more tanks
congress is like ah rubber stamp and we
just make them it's good for the economy
right china is more strategic so they've
got a longer plan than us and i do think
i'm i'm not going to be happy uh i think
most people wouldn't be happy
if they had to live the way people in
mainland china do yeah
well i mean it's kind of a leap though
from john cena
to all of us having to apologize to the
children
all day for for this that or the other
thing of course their military doctrine
our government acronym for it or you
know the way they call it i don't know
exactly the chinese term for it
is anti-access area denial
in other words it's purely defensive
their entire military strategy is about
keeping the united states
out but so yeah but it's not a blue
water navy i mean you talk about
nuclear submarines we have 22 aircraft
carriers 11
on station around the planet at all
times the u.s navy rules all the oceans
in the seven seas
the the question here is do we rule
all of the south china sea or
does china have influence in the south
china sea
and think how absurd this would be if we
were talking about china's influence in
the gulf of mexico
right right and the atlantic ocean is
now a chinese lake
absolutely absurd in the same way that
our claim
to the pacific ocean and all of those
territories
is absurd so yes we we are in a trap
if we are pledged to defend the koreas
and japan
and laos and cambodia and vietnam and
australia and every other and what uh
myanmar
and every other country in asia from
china then yes we are definitely in a
greek guy trap and we're going to have a
great guy here
but the reality is that that's not in
the interest of the american people
whatsoever so right if the chinese
like you're talking about the difference
between the people that run the american
government have all these very narrow
interests and the chinese
government seems to have kind of broader
plans
i don't think that makes them
necessarily any more of a threat you
know the defensive pact of world war one
is basically what started it someone had
a pact with i don't know was it the
austrian-hungary
hungarian empire or something yeah the
germans and the
ottomans and then so if someone got
invaded then there was a defensive
response so like if taiwan was invaded
in the american defensive response
would kick off a bunch of nations
joining and defending each other and
then a world war
but when you look at world war ii hitler
invaded poland
and if we had not done anything they set
up
basically they used the conquered area
of poland to build more military they
were using their industry
so it was they were planning to invade
russia
so at what point if you see a foreign
invasion do you do you intervene
well that's the deeply that's the deep
philosophical debate when they attack
you
but what if they attack everyone around
you and start building more weapons with
that industry
well look france is not around me and
this was the lie of the 1930s and early
40s was that
look france is our eastern frontier
well no it's not it's like five thousand
yeah france is not part of america
at all and it's not our frontier at all
these are all just
figures of speech right and in fact you
know if the
british hadn't given a war guarantee to
poland
then hitler would have never turned west
against france and denmark and belgium
and england and the western democracies
in the first place as you say
he was they split poland he split poland
with the soviet union
and on a and and made a peace with them
because he knew that he was going to
have to fight them sooner or later
but the british and the french were
insisting on fighting him
so he decided to turn against to make a
peace with stalin
and fight and destroy all the western
democracies first
and then move into the soviet union so
if the british had just stayed out of it
once he went into poland the war between
nazi germany and the soviet union was
inevitable
and he would have never felt like he had
to attack the western democracies at all
the whole thing would have been in the
east
which would have been a catastrophe for
the people in the lands between
germany and the soviet union but not for
the western democracies
it was it was this all was
self-inflicted in fact if you read pat
buchanan's book churchill
hitler and the unnecessary war they talk
about when neville chamberlain everybody
always makes fun of neville chamberlain
for making uh peace over czechoslovakia
right yeah
but he's the one who he gave the war
guarantee to poland
and as soon as he did lord gray the
foreign minister said oh my god what are
you doing they should lock this man up
in a mental hospital
are you crazy why would you give a war
guarantee to poland we have no ability
to defend poland
all you're doing is guaranteeing that
we're going to get into a war with
germany that we're not prepared to fight
yet
i mean what does any of this have to do
with fdr and the american people back
home
other than his new deal failed for three
administrations in a row and so now he
had to get us into a war so
why did uh why did hitler attack uh
the uk because they declared war on him
first
is that what happened that's what
happened yeah when they listen when that
war was over
when that war was over winston churchill
said you know
i guess we stuck the wrong pig well
didn't you yeah really huh
germany had a military force in their
west preparing to invade france
regardless i think they were ready to go
when france declared war they went like
two weeks later they went into
paris with tanks well i i don't want to
do it yeah because i want to i want to
have a belligerent that is going to
invade at what point do you say
that's declare counter war the
philosophical question that i wanted to
get to before we started going off on
the you know history stuff is
i guess the philosophical argument for
those that are war essentialists is that
well if we don't do it they will and i'd
rather be on top of the mountain than
you know the bottom of it
and that's like a very nightmarish
prospect but
i i think i don't know do you cross your
fingers and hope
no one's going to do it yeah i think
they would though i don't think they
would
you think only america is the country
that wants to have these bases
well look the american people are the
only ones who can afford it and we can't
even afford it yeah
yeah the chinese can because of the
petro dollar it's all and the reality is
we had in the cold war
with the soviet union this bipolar world
where
this really america ruled two-thirds of
the planet and the
communists ruled one-third of it right
and then when all that fell apart
this is what charles krauthammer the
neocon called our unipolar moment
this is when we get to spend the next
about 20 years making the world exactly
how we want it
before not that america will get weaker
but before the rest of the world starts
getting rich and their power starts
becoming more equal to ours and then so
this has been seen all along as an
eventuality that what we'll have is a
multi-polar world
where it matters what beijing thinks and
it matters what new delhi thinks it
matters what london thinks it matters
what sao paulo thinks
and so rio is the capital of brazil so
what you're saying is that
john cena apologetic china will kick off
world war
iii i'm kidding but let's talk about uh
so so i
we'll get we'll definitely start you
know keep the conversation going on the
philosophy of war as we move on but
let's talk about the media because we
have this other story from the hill
the memo media face hard questions on
trump and the wuhan lab
i don't i don't really need i use i'll
use the article as a reference but i
don't think i need to actually pull
anything up because we all know what
happened
donald trump very early on said the
wuhan lab lab leak
which we should investigate into it the
media went nuts said it wasn't true
fauci said it was likely not true
no i don't think so everybody said trump
was a conspiracy theorist vox.com said
theory debunked
and somehow for some reason all you know
all of a sudden the media's flipped on
this
and my my first point is like hey it's
about time people are taking this
seriously and also
wait a minute whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what happened
i don't just believe all of these
different media
institutions and political establishment
elites just decided
now oh i just realized maybe it's true
is there perhaps an agenda behind why
all of a sudden
they've decided to say yes let's
investigate wuhan
i'm not sure about that i think i i
doubt that the democrats and the overall
you know media consensuses we want to
toughen up on china and demonize china
worse now
i'm not saying like they've coordinated
anything like the media i think is just
deferential to what
the politi the the establishment elites
say apparently to me
what made the change was a guy i forget
his name
sims maybe uh who had been the new york
times science reporter for like 30 years
and this is not the guy that got fired
over saying the n-word this is a
different guy
different guy okay not the n-word guy
and that story was completely ridiculous
anyway so this is the other guy and and
they wouldn't publish the thing at the
new york times he just published
it at medium.com but it's i don't know
how many words it says at the top
47-minute read
so it's like a 20 000 word article or
something about how geez
guys we don't have the proof but it
really does look like
it was the lab and then but that means
man-made or manipulated like uh fauci
said he wasn't convinced it was
naturally occurring right so that's the
crate
and this is the deal it's this gain of
function research where they
deliberately make viruses
more and more deadly on the theory that
they can keep it locked up in the lab
and that then they can anticipate future
viruses if we're gonna
engineer a virus that attacks the ace2
receptor on your lung cells
and then we're going to figure out how
to kill that virus so that then if a
virus similar to this ends up breaking
out
into the public we'll know how to fight
it so that's the theory
but of course it's really dangerous work
because what they're doing is they're
deliberately evolving these viruses to
be more and more
contagious more and more transmissible
because otherwise it takes too long
and then to go through the steps so you
have to make it as infectious as
possible so you can hurry up
and do the next stage of the experiment
but they were doing it in a lab
that we we had repeatedly heard warnings
about for having
lacked security procedures well obama
outlawed it so
it was the it was the obama white house
requested that congress
outlaw this and they could have done it
just by executive order or something i
guess
they had congress pass a law and and ban
this
but the law has a loophole that says
that if the proper authority
determines that there's a national
emergency then you can go ahead
when it was fouchy and she signed off on
the national emergency but
we can't go ahead here but we can
finance this group
that's financing the research president
it's a national level we got to slow
down
uh and we jumped the connection okay the
u.s
was providing funding to this lab right
so can you
explain yeah so so it was under the
national institutes of health
then there's a subcontractor i'm sorry i
forgot the name of the the company
that's the subconscious
ecohealth or something yeah something
like that and then
those guys were actually the ones in
charge of the investigation as to what
happened
everybody took their word i love it
found ourselves innocent of any
wrongdoing
by the way so at the beginning um when
you said everybody denounced trump
that's not exactly right the head of the
cdc at the time
the bald guy with the beard i'm sorry i
forgot his name uh that's not redfield
is it
yes yes redfield said he thought that it
was
that it must have been engineered in a
lab and the guy and the final the famous
nobel laureate virologist said the same
thing luke what's his name i don't
remember his name um
he's called the conspiracy theorist that
he was he was he was nuts but see you
all they're like oh well fouchy said it
so when you also have josh rogan
who is you know very close to the war
party and writes for the washington post
and he's just put out a new book
about this as well that says like we
don't have the proof
but boy does it sure look like this must
be what happened
but i don't so a lot of people have
mentioned this this medium post
and there was one viral tweet that was
like think about that the only reason
the story is getting out is because
someone wrote a story on medium because
our media establishment wouldn't accept
it
and the new york times wouldn't publish
their own science reporter
but but right right right but we had
we've had whistleblowers
we we had a a a researcher out of the
university of hong kong
saying looked like a lab leak and they
knew people
who were involved in it and that was all
rejected all lies all conspiracy
trump said without evidence trump said
without evidence right all of a sudden
now this guy writes this
medium post so here's what it is here's
what it is
it's not so much about why are they open
to the possibility now
as much as why did they refuse to
discuss this possibility all last year
and you already hit the key there
because it was trump that said it
yeah and they had an agenda to hang the
virus around his neck
no matter what so and frankly
you know his leadership on the issue the
first few months there
was not so much to be admired and so
this was the thing that they're going to
use as the millstone to hang around his
neck
now if the virus came out of the lab in
china china
china that fits in with his narrative
and is handing him a point maybe a few
points
and now what's interesting though right
is that they could have turned it right
back around again
although they would have had to
sacrifice their boy fauci
they would have had to say that actually
it is trump's fault because trump wasn't
doing his job
preventing fauci from signing this
emergency authorization
to allow this virus to go on so they
could have still made it all trump's
faults anyway
but they would have had to go around the
long way yeah it was easier to just say
well
it came from nature and this guy just
did nothing but sit on his hands and
that's why everybody's dead and there's
no way they were going to let
this complicated story break out in the
summer there's become a real topic of
conversation if they could squelch it
and they did squelch it
they did not want to give trump an
opportunity for a win period so no
matter what he said
it was bad and so the media was just
their bread and butter the whole time
now cnn's ratings just on fire msnbc
everyone's in the gutter because it was
just
that's what they were living off of
anger at donald trump but let me tell
you
it's really easy to criticize the media
i think most people get it at this point
i'll tell you what's shocking to me this
story which just went up
uh like was it like now 40 minutes ago
from fox news
senate advances measure barring taxpayer
funds for china's wuhan institute of
virology
amendment added by gop senator joni
ernst of iowa
to the endless frontier act which seeks
to counter china
only now it's it's been a year and a
half
almost a year and a half of them already
had a law like this why don't they just
take out the part that says that fauci
can sign an emergency authorization
yeah that's all they gotta do is why
didn't they fire that guy
you know i will say i would love to see
one if there was one debate
that i could see between you know a
couple people would be fouchy debating
fauci
with fouchy stepping in because fauci's
been anti-mask he's been pro-mask
he's set go on cruises said cruises are
dangerous he said it's not going to be a
big deal it's going to be a really big
deal
he said uh two masks it's just common
sense he said two masks if there's no
there's no evidence suggesting and then
he said
cdc guidelines say you should wear two
masks he's just like trump
he's on all sides of every issue so you
can pick and choose and if you want to
like him then you can
go i agree with half of the stuff this
guy says that's pretty good we need him
so i i know like you mentioned the other
day lydia that crowder had a uh
you know fouchy debating fouchy but we
need an updated fauci debating fauci
because boy part two yeah he could
really debate himself
you know why he you know why he was
first famous was because
when the aids epidemic was first
breaking out in the 1980s he was the guy
who pushed that no
we must only fund vaccine research
and we must do everything we can to
thwart people who are trying to come up
with medications
to treat it now here we are in the year
2021
there's no aids vaccine yeah there's no
vaccine for hiv there never has been
they
you know tried working on it from time
to time um
the reason well i don't know but the
reason that
people survive with aids now is because
of the drugs
that fauchies suppressed and you know i
saw on twitter someone
uh showed an old sign of uh aids rally
and from like 1984 or 1985
and the guy said the guy's sign says dr
fauci you're killing us
wow really yeah i i i just i we got this
next story from
about and it was azt was the big drug
that he was trying to suppress and that
was the first big breakthrough drug that
helped
aids patients wow wait azt yeah is is
that the same drug that's been brought
up as a zethromycin
or no i don't know no i don't know well
so but they made a matthew mcconaughey
movie out of this the drug buyers club
or was it the buyers club oh yeah
dallas buyers club yeah where this is
it's aids patients and dr fauci
won't let them buy medicine so they got
to go down to mexico to get the
medicines
that's who this guy is 40 years he's
been entrenched in this industry at
least
and seriously let's just entertain the
possibility because it's not proven yet
okay but let's just say that
he signed this emergency authorization
that allowed the money to go to this
subcontractor to continue pushing this
research at wuhan fauci just killed a
couple of million people
including about 600 000 americans i
don't know what was the last count of
number of americans who've died of this
thing but i guarantee you it's higher
than the official council
the excess death rate is much higher
let's do some math and be fair all right
um
if everybody wore a mask from the get-go
according to cdc that would have helped
prevent the spread
so they say uh okay well then if
everybody did there'd be a lot less debt
right
well in the beginning fauci said not to
wear a mask because he wanted to make
sure the doctors got it right he later
admitted that that
well you know we said that because we
were worried the doctors wouldn't get it
right as i pointed out yesterday
the reason the doctors need the masks is
because people aren't wearing masks it's
because people don't wear masks get sick
and then go to the hospital
and so the doctors need to wear them too
right if everybody was wearing masks
you'd have a lot less people in
hospitals doctors wouldn't need as many
fauci lied and people died and he could
have just said listen
please for the love of god everybody
save the n95s for the doctors yes
but wear two bandanas or something yeah
he could have said wear a scarf
sure i mean people walk around with
masks they take a handkerchief he could
he could he could've said you don't need
the n95s just pull your shirt up and put
something over your face
instead he lied because he was worried
that people would buy the medical
supplies although
you know at this point and and honestly
i don't read up on the germ nearly as
much as i was a year ago
so i am behind on this but it really
looks like the masks are red herring
because you know tom woods sends out his
daily email and one of the things that
he's constantly doing is comparing the
states
with the different levels of mass
mandate at the same time and the curves
are always
well this this just got i think they
have studies that say that like if you
and i are wearing masks
we're less likely to transfer it to each
other here and now in this room
but if you try to extrapolate that out
and say you have to
everyone in virginia what must wear a
mask it doesn't work and it doesn't make
it
you got to wash your mask too yeah well
here's here's here's and the reason
wait one more thing the reason they
thought the masks worked so well in the
first place was because in countries
like south korea
and in china and hong kong and taiwan
they were all wearing masks
and not getting very sick but that
wasn't what it was
it only seemed like it it was because
they have a much stronger immunity to
coronavirus and china
because they're exposed to many more
coronaviruses than we do so here's
here's here's the big challenge right
now we've seen texas and florida
they they dropped everything they said
we're open for business and a bunch of
republican states are the same thing
and joe biden comes out and this was
this was months ago he was like we're
gonna we might need a longer lockdown
and and more restrictions
and and everyone was joking like go to
florida who's biden talking to
the problem is youtube we're at risk
right now i'm getting totally pulled off
just for even bringing this up there
have been channels that have been
outright deleted
with no warning for simply mentioning
what you just said
but what are we supposed to do when we
have clear examples in the political
arena
of states and then when fauci is brought
on the today show and they say how do
you explain this he goes i can't
right then why are we listening to this
guy a tv doctor
who doesn't know what he's talking about
and for some reason
they act like he's an expert they make
action figures of him they call it the
fauci ouchy
that is a cult i'm sorry this guy's not
an expert he clearly doesn't know what
he's talking about
right and they're acting like what he
says is gospel i like tucker carlson's
take on this he goes you know
this guy with all his lockdowns and all
his recommendations
i think maybe he's over compensating for
something here
that this guy he's known all along he's
the one who did this to us
he's the one who unleashed this virus on
the planet
and now he's going around talking about
how you and you and you aren't doing
enough to protect yourself i thought you
were going to say something else
are there so have you one second do you
remember the episode of the simpsons
where
they i don't know what happened there
was like a council took over
and then comic book guy is like trying
to pass a law and he goes like
we as the most logic logical species in
the galaxy the vulcans
mating will now be will now take place
only once every seven years
for most of you this will be much much
less mating but for me much much more
yeah so the joke would be found she's
like we're gonna lock down because then
you know nobody can
have you know in the uk they actually
you couldn't have you couldn't go and
have sex with somebody like
actually banned that stuff is there
that's where i thought you were going i
was like fauci's like he's an old man
are there examples of gain of function
do working i don't know that's a good
question like
whether they actually ever preempted a
naturally occurring virus because they'd
been doing such a good job experimenting
on possible ones i don't think so
i think we would have heard of that
right well that's not how they stop mers
that's not how they stop sars
they stopped those because you had to
have a really high fever to spread it
and so they were able to just
lock everybody down and i think so
spread to canada
and they just kept it in one city and it
never but from there we're not supposed
to know about what's going on in the
wuhan lab and we don't know about what's
going on in american labs to us to a
great degree a lot of it's just
classified secret and the american labs
have better security
protocols so better if this it's looking
more and more like lab leak
is legit i mean the wall street journal
said three people from the lab were
hospitalized
hospitalized with this with some similar
illness and they only told us that
two days ago that's right that's right
and they knew the reports from 29 was it
the report was from last year i think
right yeah it was a cia report and you
would
get banned on youtube for saying it you
would get banned on youtube for saying
all of these things the media is now
saying oh yeah i guess so fouchy himself
coming out and saying this and it's like
i gotta
i got to worry about censorship so we
were right back to the larger point
about the media
right and this is a headline i actually
didn't get a chance to read it yet but i
saw matt taibi's new piece it's called
the death of fact checking yes oh yeah
that's it how is it how is glenn kessler
at the washington post going to pretend
to be a fact checker
when he's not right he doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about a fact
claimed they debunked tucker carlson's
show because they got an
expert to give their opinion that is not
how you debunk something
if someone makes a video and there is an
eagle that picks up a baby and flies
away which is like a viral video that
happened at some point
you debunk it by investigating the
source material
putting it through like an analysis to
track like the you know like
um light and artifacts in the in the
video and then point to it and say
here's my my my proposal i believe this
is evidence
and then you have an expert opinion
breaking down all the facts right
just having some guy go on tv and say
he's got an opinion i got an opinion
okay yours is the correct opinion thank
you have a nice day that's not debunking
anything
okay look they say trust the science but
what they mean is trust the scientists
that we have here saying things when
science itself
is nothing but a process for debunking
things it's not something to be trus i
mean you can trust it in the sense that
it's an effective way to try to debunk
things but it's not
a set of answers in a book somewhere
that you just
instead of god we have science now so we
just believe whatever he says
but right there's nobody there we have
we have this guy i want to show you this
will compete real quick luke
montagnier he is a french virologist and
the joint recipient of the francois
barra sinui i pronouncing it wrong
and blah blah blah of the 2008 nobel
prize in physiology of medicine for his
discovery
of the human immunodeficiency virus hiv
down over
chronovirus pandemic they say this is
not his wikipedia page
montagne argued that the chronovirus
disease 2019 was man-made in a
laboratory
and that it might have been the result
of an attempt to create a vaccine for
hiv
his allegations came after the united
states had launched a probe into whether
the virus came from a laboratory
according to maintania the presence of
elements of hiv and germ of malaria in
the genome of the chronovirus is highly
suspect
for and the characteristics of the virus
could not have arisen naturally
initially this was described as a
conspiracy vision
that does not relate to real science by
jean francois
del del frasie probably pronouncing that
wrong
an immunologist and the head of the
scientific council that advises the
french government on the coven pandemic
however anthony fauci the director of
the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
admitted on may 11 2021 that he no
longer is convinced that covet 19
originated naturally this guy was called
a conspiracy theorist
and he is a nobel prize-winning
virologist and only now because
fauci agrees with him we're supposed to
now say okay no no
when the when the when the award-winning
virologist comes out and says here's
what i think we go wow
i mean he's the expert right hey there
the cdc said the same thing but
let me let me point this out when tucker
carlson has a guest on the show
who can cite an award-winning nobel
laureate for his
hypothesis not even statement of fact
and politifact says
we got some guy who gave us his opinion
that you're wrong so it's debunked
and then vox and all these other outlets
and cnn can say it's fake news now
right how is it reality for these fact
checkers
when they don't uh the experts the
actual award-winning experts are at odds
with them
who are these random people they put in
the news and then claim our experts to
debunk what you're saying
it's fake news they're writing fake
stories this vox reporter i tweeted
about this
she wrote a fabricated story vox.com
wrote
fake news when is what are any of these
fact checkers going to come out i need
these organizations newsguard i'm
talking to you
i use you guys i reference newsguard who
get who cites
are you gonna go now to every single one
of these outlets that debunked
lab leak with no evidence and and their
debunk was an opinion from some guy and
now claim they publish fake news
what if i get a former cia official who
comes and talks about some crazy
conspiracies involving aliens well i got
a cia official it must be true
they do this all the time they pick and
choose based on what they think is
socially acceptable but you know what
there's a reason why your show
pulls more viewers than any show on cnn
because people
are over it in the key demo they got the
old people
okay yeah we got the younger people and
remember too by the way i had forgotten
about this but there were two
indian virologists at the very beginning
who said they thought it was a lab leak
because of the presence of what they
recognized as pieces of hiv
and some of them they were told that
they were complete kooks remember that
and some of them
some of these uh initial reports these
initial publications were retracted
because the media said so because people
were scared their reputations would be
destroyed
well this guy this luke montagna guy
he's 88 i'm sure he doesn't care much
about anything at this point he's like
i'm just going to say it
and it's it's this first of all
please use this as an another example we
often have many examples
to your friends and family when they're
like i trust the media say
here you go here you go fauci is now
admitting they called
the nobel prize winner who discovered
aids a conspiracy hiv sorry a conspiracy
theorist for saying in my expert opinion
having discovered
hiv this is what i think about this they
were like conspiracy
what how he he didn't he didn't say it
was a conspiracy he didn't
he didn't suggest a group of people came
together to commit a crime in secret
he's just like people do gain a function
all the time in fact if you go back a
year
what they would say about this always in
fact i remember tucker carlson
refuting the debunking of his show
is they put words in his mouth that he
said it was a biological weapon that had
that was being used deliberately
i never said anything about a weapon
nobody ever thought nobody ever claimed
that if somebody's working on germs in a
laboratory that that's
biological weapons research what we
think
may have happened here was somebody
accidentally got infected which happens
and then they spread it and it got out
to the world and they go oh no you're
debunking
the stephen king they made a movie the
stand and they were working on a virus
in like florida and one of them
emergency and then everyone's like
freaking out one of the employees is
like
i gotta get out i gotta save my family
and get out of the city they lock the
whole city down he like
escapes and gets his family and flees to
texas gets to a gas station and spreads
it to like eight people and then that's
how
yeah or like in uh 28 days later when
they have the chimp infected and they're
doing experiments and then
the eco animal activists free it no
right zombies spread or whatever
this is what the fact checkers mine
that's why they're so afraid of this
idea of a lab leak is because movies
like that
this is this is what fact checkers do at
these organizations like snopes and like
politifact
they'll say something like oh you know
scott horton's here on the tim cats
podcast and
fact check did you know people will be
people have claimed on twitter that
scott horton appeared on the tim cast
irl show
question did scott horton appear on the
tim cast irl podcast
dot dot dot with ice cream false
yeah and then it's like no one ever said
he had ice cream but they add that tiny
little bit that makes no sense
and the whole thing becomes fake and
then at the bottom they'll say
you know they'll give you a bunch of
verbose garbage you don't want to read
where it'll be like in 2017 you know in
2017 tim poole dude you got the idea for
putting a show and i'll talk about this
nonsense and then right at the bottom in
one sentence
while he did appear on the show he did
not have ice cream
so people see these fact checks and they
screen cap and they share with their
friends see it's false it's not true
yeah actually read it why don't you
that's what the media does
you got to show the stuff you lie to
people so many times in a row you
radicalize the hell out of them and make
them mad as hell i mean this is the deal
just keep doing the same thing over and
over and over to people
because it stops working i hope that
fauci will be
one of the greatest tools in waking
people up to the lies
of the establishment and the media just
we need just like a 30-second clip of
fauci contradicting himself in really
dumb ways
and you can be like it's really proven
that he did this
that this really does come from his
so what the what the fact check said is
well you know so so
rand paul questioned fauci in in this
congressional hearing
and fauci denied providing we never
funded any of this you are
wrong and that's not true the funding
was provided
but what was really funny is politifact
said well they were
technically doing gain of function
research but there's different
definitions of what that means so it's
not necessarily true
but what really happened is that yes
there was money provided by the nih but
it was kind of like a general
pool wasn't allocated so even though
they used some of it for gain of
function we don't
it's like did they really basically what
they're saying is
well they didn't explicitly sign off do
gain a function research therefore rand
paul is wrong
so like if you were building this but
they did if you were building a skate
park and i was like well here let me
allocate a bunch of money to you to do
whatever you want with it and you're
like okay i'll build
this skate park with it and i'm like and
then when i didn't give you money to
build the skate park
right i gave you money you were building
a skate park and you used it to build
the skates so we'll break it down
ian ian get put puts a million dollars
up tim will built a skate park with that
money
and then when someone says ian you
funded the creation of this skate park
he was no i didn't
and then the fact check says false ian
provided a million dollars for general
purposes
it wasn't to build a skate park while it
is true that tim will built a skate park
and there it is yes the money came from
the u.s government from this source
yes it went to wuhan yes they did this
thing but
they didn't mean to that's the media
that's the game
the weird thing is i am more comfortable
and at ease with this whole thing
knowing it's from a lab
than thinking it just came from nature
well you don't know it's from a lab
assuming that it
thinking if i could pick thinking that
we were working on a virus that
infected some people and and it is way
easier and like good okay at least we're
trying to do something
as opposed to just naturally some random
virus came and started destroying
humanity
in fact the sars and mers were like the
two novel viruses
from the last 20 years and luckily
and they were very dangerous but they
were only very dangerous to a small
number of people they were able to
contain them
so so so this is actually one of the
hypotheses
is that they were bringing bats in
because they were doing experiments on
covet on the bat coronavirus because of
how dangerous it was
and the gain of function research was an
attempt to create a vaccine i'm not
saying that's true
those are some of the theories that are
in some of these mainstream publications
talking about what may have happened
and then it leaked from the lab there
was a story about uh i i
we covered this we talked about on the
show that one of the people got sprayed
with like bat urine or something someone
got bit
so these stories were already out there
but you run the risk
of google banning you if you dare bring
it up
the double standard the media is allowed
to claim everything's a conspiracy
theory
they're allowed to determine what is or
isn't true and google just allows it
they censor and suppress
it back to 2016. this is all because of
the giant
fake russia hoax all of this comes from
the lie
that donald trump and the russians
colluded to steal the election of 2016.
and then how do we get from there to
there because all of this censorship
comes from that you know whatever you're
saying that disagrees with the party
line this is russian disinformation
you're not just wrong this is
dangerous and you're a de facto agent of
a foreign power and all this so this is
when they really started de-ranking
people from google searches
uh when they really started kicking
people off of twitter and facebook
and just like with the germ here for
getting things exactly right
for saying that the russia hoax was
absolutely a hoax that's juarez
wasn't a traitor he was a loyal american
patriot
and let's talk about exactly right when
tucker brought up lab leak
he didn't definitively state it was or
wasn't he said these are interesting
questions
he was exactly right to ask those
questions which are now being admitted
to by fouchy but the media said it was a
lie
you can't trust these people and so and
you know i know a lot of people
they love watching this show i i i
uh there's there's a bias fact checker
thing that people were posting
and it was really funny it said that tim
on twitter tim poole has a has a
right-wing blind spot meaning
most of the stories i i tweet about are
from the left but it's because
mainstream media is the left so i use
news guard which i referenced earlier
rather angrily
they certify what is or isn't factual
news that they'll be like oh this
website has bad standards and has good
standards
daily wire is rated as having bad
standards it's a conservative opinion
website
that what what they report on is fact
based it's just their opinions their
opinions can be wrong
right media matters which is just
activism
is rated green across the board right so
it's not that i have a left bias it's
that
the organizations the institutions have
an institutional
left establishment bias a liberal bias
right they hate the left
they'll go after them persecute real
leftists you know they they um
they'll use them yeah once they started
kicking all the right wingers off of
twitter
then they went well no but and and d
ranking them on google
they said no but we're being fair
because we're also picking on the left
too and they went after truth dig truth
out
the world socialist website which is the
trotskyites
and they threw antiwar.com in there even
though we're libertarians i guess they
just assume we're leftist so we got
de-ranked by google along with everybody
else
in the name of fairness because they're
picking on these people but
they didn't kick the liberals off they
kicked the leftists that's right
uh occupy wall street activists got
banned i saw you you guys got listed
in uh a a it was a blacklist of some
sort probably google
and i remember talking to a bunch of
conservatives being like dude they're
going after the people who oppose the
establishment right
it's not they'll they'll gleefully use
the leftists
and unfortunately a lot of a lot of
these young leftists
don't know who these people are they
don't they weren't they weren't around
in politics when joe biden was vice
president
so they think he's the hero or or to be
fair
the dsa types in the early 20s think
sure he's bad
but he's not a fascist and i'm like i
got news for you about the biden
obama years and what biden was doing
with his brother so make sure
call them whatever you want crooked how
about that but they weren't around for
it yeah so they vote for this guy
they get exploited and that's why
democrats love younger voters
a 16 year old doesn't have the memory of
what they did 10 years ago
exploitation that's the name of the game
so they'll censor
everybody but here here's what ends up
happening trump
was very powerful in terms of upsetting
the establishment
trump's followers were very prominent
and influential
they had to get rid of those people they
cut it they smack it from the middle
and then trump loses a lot of his core
uh
evangelizers these these prominent
personalities that means less grassroots
you know people rising up they ban
subreddits like the donald this massive
subreddit where people are posting memes
and having a good time
they cut it out from the ground up and
then trump falls
they had to go after him with all of
their force that means the conservatives
were getting the brunt of the censorship
but there were very much so many
leftists who were anti-establishment as
well
and screaming and saying f.u to the
democrats the whole way
and they got nuked too but there were
there were fewer of them
so what ends up happening is the whole
narrative becomes conservative
the liberals end up just saying it's a
fake it's fake news conservatives are
lying it's a private company
and then many leftists who get banned
apparently weren't loud enough because
leftists are always fighting with each
other as well
a lot of leftists decided to align
themselves with democrats because
as they described it it's easier to
overthrow a feeble old man than it is a
fascist so they decided they were going
to support joe biden
for some reason they didn't then speak
up for their for their own
or if they did and this is the problem a
conservative gets banned
the leftist laughs the leftist gets
banned and then demands the
conservatives stand up for them
and the conservative does some
conservatives started saying you know
what screw you i'm gonna laugh as you
get canceled
but this is the problem of censorship it
is the democratic establishment and the
old neocon establishment which got
fractured as soon as trump stormed into
the party but all those people the
lincoln project people
are very much still aligned with all of
the democrats they've become one big
they've always been one big unit party
but now there's like real
opposition fomenting and ultimately
i think the censorship will get worse i
think it'll impact us
we've talked a great deal about it the
the lab leak theory we weren't allowed
to talk about you know we were we'd be
very careful in talking about it
and now here we are with fauci himself
deciding it's okay and now now it's okay
yeah well you know i think it's really
one of the major crises of our era is
the left
the the further left really giving up on
freedom of speech
and and bringing the liberals with them
you know it used to be the liberals were
the ones who would go to court to fight
for your right to say whatever you want
that they disagree with but
because they really don't yeah they've
taken really much more of a
totalitarian uh sort of a left you know
my friend anthony gregory says
it used to always be the best thing
about the left was that they weren't the
liberals
and the best thing about the liberals
was that they weren't the left yeah
because you need them both right because
the liberals have made their peace with
capitalism
and and guns and i mean they're not
coming
them no no the liberals are the anti-gun
ones the leftists love guns
yeah i don't know the traditionally the
liberals have
they have their background checks and so
forth but they're not taking them the
left disagreement
listen listen right now the leftists on
twitter are posting karl marx
under no pretext shall arms and
ammunition be surrendered the workers
must frustrate
frustrate this by force if necessary
well listen the liberals literally
banned a bunch of my guns
well that's true that there there are
some leftists who are good on guns but i
i think that those kind of quotes are
pretty rare
among among the real hard left but
especially like on things like speech
um and and war so it used to be that you
could rely on the leftists
to be against imperialism to oppose the
fbi and the cia and all these things
and you could rely on the liberals to um
you know essentially support capitalism
and not be you know the worst on
but like neo-liberal capitalism that's
right yeah absolutely right
corporate garbage the hillary clinton
compromise
so yeah we're talking about we're not
talking about libertarianism we're
talking about right the center left
democrats
but then what happened was trump was so
polarizing that he pushed the
leftists and the liberals together but
only for the worse
right so the liberals abandoned their
belief in free speech
so that they could collaborate with the
leftists on kicking everybody else off
and then the leftists abandoned all of
their opposition to not
all but they're in large measure their
opposition to imperialism
and to the federal police agencies
because who's protecting us from donald
trump
the fbi and the cia they love it and so
everybody rally around john brennan and
robert mueller
because they're protecting us from the
big bad fascists this is what as i said
because i i was
i've known i've known all of these
occupy people these these leftists
i said it was the greatest
deradicalization in the history of the
united states
when i see the the the far left is from
occupy cheering for the fbi
and that's all i would do so so i'm on
facebook and i see this hacker guy
this this guy who's like literally been
to prison of opposing and
fighting you know and being a far
leftist and then he's like the fbi's
raided giuliani's office this is you
know amazing he's like finally justice
and i was like i'm so happy to see that
you stepped back from the edge
and you've come towards liberalism and
now you accept the fbi and the federal
government as your saviors and you're no
longer on the side of committing crimes
then another hacker comes in and
and she's saying she's like yes finally
and i'm like
wow i am so impressed i remember you
sleeping on the floor of that hacker
collective
talking about how you hated the federal
government and imperialism and now here
you are cheering for it
i'm just i'm so impressed with your
willingness to finally see the light and
step away from this and they don't know
you're
being sarcastic they're like yeah thanks
they're like wow myself on the back too
well no they're not all that dumb but
it's like my point was made
and one guy's like well i we're allowed
to be happy when our enemies are getting
hurt
and i was like right you support
fascists when they're doing things you
like
that makes you a fascist sympathizer
there's the door
don't say that to me about donald trump
when you scream fascism and the moment
you come in and defend
authoritarian measures from the
government i'm supposed to act like
you're special
no no no yeah you don't get to play that
game donald trump was a human molotov
cocktail
he got thrown in the room he was a bull
in a china shop he was a bona ivory
tower whatever whatever whatever you
want to say
you know call him but these people got
so wrapped up in media propaganda
they went insane they were probably
already insane
uh like being re-radicalized is easy if
you live in hate like if they hated the
government and wanted to
tear it down without like a new creation
system that they had an in plan
then it's easy to take those people and
redivert their hate towards something
else like the media pushed us towards
trump they tried so much so then they
just used the hate
the establishment hated trump but i will
i will say one thing too
what you need to keep in mind about the
left is that while
many of these leftists that i'm talking
about are my age
a lot of the support they get are from
people who are 20 who don't know
anything about this they were 10 years
old during occupy wall street
they don't know so donald trump comes
along they're teenagers
before they were born that's right
that's right and
uh they're babies you know when all the
stuff is going down uh
when when a lot a lot of these people
were babies or toddlers or kids
even if they were alive they didn't know
anything about it right so i'm like what
what makes you think voting for joe
biden is going to make things better and
we actually had a conversation with this
guy
and his response was oh i was like a
little kid i was like a teenager during
occupy i don't know anything about it
i'm like so so when joe biden takes over
overseeing the iraq war
and then all of a sudden his brother
starts getting the contracts not
suspicious to you
that's what you want to come in i take
the i take the crazy orange man
because at the very least the abraham
accords i loved it
he he wasn't perfect firing tomahawk
missiles very bad
john bolton very bad trying
to to any degree to get troops out of
the middle east i was like just
i'll take what i can get instead we get
the the the neocon establishment again
this time just
biden he's sitting in his little
wheelchair with his
blank on his lap going as they just
pulled the trigger for him
and they just what as soon as he gets in
what do we get missile strikes in syria
unsurprising but anyway i want to uh
well let's fight about the abraham
accords you don't like abraham accords
no not at all why not
well first of all they're not any kind
of peace deal
economic deals yeah the uae in bahrain
and sudan and morocco none of them were
at war with israel
uae and and sudan declared war on israel
in 67
but didn't send any troops but so these
aren't really peace deals what these are
is
sell out the palestinians on the
american pax
on the american taxpayers dime but
weren't weren't you saying before that
the trade deals with china would be
beneficial and help keep things
simmered down and prevent conflict sure
it's that there's just
hasn't been any conflict to prevent
between morocco and
it's it's not just what's happened is
it's planes flying over
israel and flying over these countries
to and from i mean it's it's normalizing
economics it's like the first step
towards stabilizing the region yeah but
you had to buy a bunch of f-35s for the
uae in order to get them to do it
and the real purpose of it is not
generating peace
and these guys have all been working
together with the israelis all along
anyway unofficially
what it really is is they're selling out
the palestinians because the palestinian
the deal had always been that these arab
states would not normalize relations
with israel until they gave the
palestinians an independent state
or equal rights within israel and they
didn't do that
and then what happened was jared kushner
went over there and said what's your
price
i have the american people's money in my
pocket i can spend as much of it as i
want
so what will it cost tim
what were you doing to sell out the
palestinians and i said well we'll take
some f-35s and we'll take some more of
your tax money and why should why should
i care about palestine
well muhammad atta crashed flight 11
into the north tower as revenge for what
the israelis were doing in palestine and
in lebanon
so it's actually an argument it's an
argument for us to not be involved
it's an argument for us absolutely to
not be involved but the thing is we are
involved the us backs
everything that the israelis do so
always have i i
you know i mentioned this when you know
cassandra came on the show came on the
show country fairbanks she's very
anti-war and she was like
you're going to hear a lot of propaganda
about why china is doing this that or
otherwise and we should not go to war
it's none of our business and i'm like
you know it's i
don't really have an argument for that
it's like are we going to get involved
in every single conflict
so for me it's like what can we do to
remove ourselves from these situations
to to a greater degree as soon as
uh biden gets in the funding for for
both sides to various degrees resumes
and conflict
lights back up and that's good for
imperialism in the for the united states
it's an excuse now to put more military
into the middle east oh no it's
destabilizing oh there's there's warren
conflict
instead we should just be like sure
maybe it cost money maybe we provided
weapons and stuff it's i don't know the
answers man i just know
under trump we were closer to getting
out of these these wars no new wars
and trump actually trying to pull troops
out and it was the establishment cronies
lying to the american people about the
troops in syria and trying to stop this
from happening
so i look at it like trade normalization
peace deals recognition of israel the
less the less conflict the better
and get our troops out and be done with
it i think you're conflating separate
things together
him trying to get out of iraq and syria
and afghanistan
is one thing his israel policy
was absolutely horrible and made
everything that much worse he recognized
israel's absolutely illegal seizure of
the golan heights and their illegal
annexation of it in 1981
and said just on a whim i recognize it
officially now it's fine
then he moved the american embassy from
tel aviv to
jerusalem which is an important symbolic
move meaning that america now recognizes
all of jerusalem as a single unified
city under jewish control when the law
says that east jerusalem is illegally
occupied by the israelis
and trump just said well screw that and
what that did was it negated even the
possibility of there being an
independent palestinian state with east
jerusalem as its capital
and it also raises the very important
question of whether
jewish extremists are going to destroy
the al-aqsa mosque and rebuild the third
temple and start sacrificing animals and
start world war three i
i think trump didn't care at all about
any of it well he cared about sheldon
adelson giving him money for the
republican party
but sheldon adelson gave him what like
50 million dollars that's trump changed
to donald trump he could have paid for
the entire his own entire re-election
and the entire republican party's
re-election and told sheldon adelson to
go to hell he said it was a mistake for
him to hire john bolton oh yeah
john bolton called him from shetland
sheldon adelson's office in las vegas
and he said probably
that's where i am right now i want a job
and trump gave him the job that's right
he should have told him to go to hell
absolutely well he's dead now thank
goodness but he
was a extremely important mega donor
and hardcore zionist and america said
his only regret was that he joined the
u.s
army instead of the idf he said he is
the one who publicly said that obama
should drop a nuke outside of tehran
as a warning and if they don't obey
after that he ought to nuke the capital
city
and john's a total nut and john bolton
was the guy who said this time next year
we'll be celebrating in tehran
so the dude wanted to just invade and
people don't understand you can't
iran is not some tiny you know country
people don't understand
the the geographics but but uh
i don't uh i don't have all the answers
so i don't i
i don't know everything about all of
these conflicts take a look at what they
did with morocco for this abraham accord
as
they call them all the abrahamic courts
i think it's originally only
bahrain and uae but then lump in sudan
and morocco
well morocco has been illegal occupying
the northern part of western sahara
for like 20 years and trump went yeah go
ahead you can have it
right so this is the liberal but but
hold on hold on rules-based world order
that america is supposedly enforcing but
the rules
don't apply to us they don't apply to
our friends we do whatever we want
the so the israelis are in violation of
the fourth geneva convention
by transferring their civilian
population into occupied territory
oh well what's a geneva convention so
this is this is the problem
then should the united states just said
we're done with all of it we're out
bye-bye you have a nice day absolutely
and it seems i'm sorry for backing these
criminals
against these helpless civilians this
population that has been occupied
for 54 years longer than the soviets
occupied trump
doesn't care about those other countries
that's right so there's
no going to trump and being like all he
cares about is america
all he wants is the is is the border
secured and factories back in america to
make america great
and so when you say yeah but these
people i don't know or care about any of
that
sign the deal get it done and get us out
of there we're out of it no new wars
trying to withdraw our troops and they
lied to keep them in place true
so he also deliberately escalated the
war in afghanistan
he deliberately escalated the war in
syria until they finished iraq war three
against the islamic state there but
that's right
right escalated the war in somalia and
he took
wherever there's um at the war in in uh
yemen and the war in somalia
he made official areas of active
hostilities
which under the law means that now the
military and the cia can kill far
more people than in more restrictive
circumstances where it's covert action
only
increase in drone strikes right massive
increase in in airstrikes drones and
planes in afghanistan and somalia and
yemen
and um he delegated the battlefield
authority
for the right to call in a strike as far
down the chain of command as he possibly
could
because when he came in there are all
these check boxes that obama and his
lawyers had added
and they killed tens of thousands of
people with their drone war but they had
added all these bureaucratic check boxes
but trump was raised on the myth of
vietnam and h.w bush talked about this
during iraq war one as well as this was
i don't know if you're familiar with
this but this was a big deal when i was
growing up
that lyndon johnson tied the hands of
the generals behind their back
nitpicking and pouring over the map in
the white house
and picking the targets himself and
controlling the policy
and if and if he hadn't done that then
the generals would have just done the
right thing
so trump said that's never going to
happen to me
no one is ever going to say that i
didn't let the military
have carte blanche to do whatever they
think is right in whatever
area and so when he came in he said i
want out of afghanistan it's in march
of of 2017
and when they were doing a review and
trying to get him to push to escalate
and he said i hereby order all american
troops out of afghanistan and out of
south korea this is in the newest bob
woodward book rage
trump said this trump said this in in
three months into three months
into power two months into power and
james mattis the secretary of defense
that he hired
yup said belay that order yup we're not
leaving afghanistan and we're not
leaving korea and i don't give a damn
what the president said and then it was
three months later trump announced he
was sending another 10
000 men to afghanistan and massively
escalating the air war
absolutely was one of the biggest
problems with trump is that he hired a
bunch of morons and didn't fire the
other morons
john bolton right obviously and yes i
think the problem was
clearly it sounds like trump just said
we i wanna the american people want out
but he was he was surrounded by people
that he should not have trusted
and he gave him including right
including his own people right he
couldn't trust
he obviously could not trust mcmaster
and mattis but he couldn't trust bannon
either and this is in
i forget if this is in fire and fury or
fear by woodward
one of the other of those i don't
necessarily trust the guy but
well no but it's it's horse's mouth
stuff so it's like when mattis tells
woodward and that's when i said
don't do what the president said you can
pretty much believe that you know what i
mean
um is that treason and well certainly
it's criminal insubordination
right i don't know exactly what you know
which law in the military code of unity
but see bannon made the deal bannon made
the deal with mattis
that listen we'll shut up about
afghanistan if you guys promise to get
worse on china
and then mattis goes well sure we wanted
to build up against china anyway
and in exchange for that you're going to
shut up about afghanistan
deal and so it was bannon that sold out
trump on afghanistan
just three months into the thing and
then they got rid of him by what july
and then in august they announced the
big escalation yeah and then you know
there's a story in the post this also
comes from mattis straight out of the
horse's mouth
that in the washington post that trump
complained why are we in somalia
i don't even want to be in somalia where
is somalia
what are we doing in somalia and james
mattis told this ridiculous lie that
well we're trying to prevent a time
square attack
well the time square attack of 2010 was
direct retaliation
for the drone war in pakistan had
nothing to do with a somali
and drone strikes didn't prevent it
drone strikes
caused it okay but then but wait it gets
better then trump
said no but i don't care i don't want to
be there i don't understand why we have
to be there
and mattis told trump quote you have
no choice and then what did trump do
he obeyed the secretary of defense
instead of saying
actually i do have the choice you're the
one who doesn't have a choice mr
secretary
he said okay fine escalate the war what
do i care if they kill another couple of
ten thousand somalis
trump should have uh for one fired a lot
of morons
not hired a lot of morons and he should
have just
done he why didn't he just go on public
tv and say this is the plan we're doing
it
look i mean the truth is it's because he
doesn't read he doesn't know anything
right if he knew anything at all tim he
would have gone to cato
and he would have gone to the national
interest and he would have said i want
all of the most credentialed anti-war
right-wingers that you guys can line up
for me let's do this
think about how close we were honestly
if trump
in the first three months says out out
but he was too busy surrounding himself
by bad people and special interests and
he was too busy complaining about
his crowd size at his inauguration and
every other stupid thing that didn't
matter at all
and selling weapons to saudi arabia to
fund the yemen yeah and so genocide
basically yeah we'll get to yemen in a
minute but i mean when he came in bannon
said here's our deal okay
we want uh to end all the free trade
agreements
we want to haul immigration from mexico
and we want to end all the wars
well guess what trump has total power
over one of those issues
the wars right and that's all he had to
do
was say i really mean this i'm really
sticking with this
we are ending these wars and if he'd
done that
it also would have been absolutely
brilliant politics
throwing a nuclear hand grenade into the
democratic party
and making the liberals attack him from
the right for ending wars
and convincing the leftists well they
never hated liberals so much
they did that right the media absolutely
did that they were claiming that trump
was
you know leaving was irresponsible and
it was a gift to these dictators and
isis
and clearly trying to negotiate peace
was just him appeasing dictators and all
that stuff appeasing putin that was
you know what i love this one you can
check this in the washington post
everybody go check in the washington
post everybody
in june it was june or july of 2017
trump ordered an end to the cia program
backing the al-qaeda terrorists the
al-nusra front aka
hyatt to rear al-sham in syria and the
washington post headline reads
in move sure to please vladimir putin
trump orders end of covert action
program in syria so
they accuse him of treason for stopping
a program of arming
al qaeda terrorists suicide bomber head
chopper murderers
we've definitely established in this
episode don't trust the media so don't
trust them man especially not the
washington post
i do have to do a hard segue because we
went a little long on this one we got to
talk about ian's favorite subject
yes so this might be the the
probably the scariest story i've ever
seen one the one that truly freaks me
out the most
wokeness at fed's regional banks puts
central bank independence at risk
fed is supposed to operate free from
political influence
oh okay okay i love it whenever anybody
types that with a straight face
oh the federal reserve yeah no they
don't engage in politics at all
right right why would they so uh they
say federal reserve banks in atlanta
boston minneapolis recently dedicated
resources to social policy
policy reflecting the political leaning
of officials who are neither elected nor
confirmed by the senate
the federal reserve's mission statement
mandates central bank to achieve maximum
employment
and stable prices while being free from
political influence
experience has shown that countries with
independent central banks achieve better
outcomes
pursuing a highly politicized social
agenda unrelated to monetary policy
is inflicting reputational damage on the
minneapolis atlanta and boston fed banks
and the federal reserve as a whole the
first thing i'm scared of but hold on
there's some good news here
is that the fed is the machine by which
they control things
and extract like essentially hidden
taxes on people printing money borrowing
money
and then your savings become worthless
and then they can use it to fund war and
other things like that
getting woke just means creepy dogmatic
authoritarianism
however it is also instability
it is wokeness is meritless it is about
instituting policy on the basis of what
feels good in our emotions
and our idea ideology as opposed to what
works
so it's kind of like well we've seen
wokeness
destroy institutions right we say get
woke go broke
so it may be scary what happens when the
federal reserve starts instituting
policy in a very massive
level but at the same time what if the
fed gets woke and goes broke
huh what what what happens huh what what
would happen if i don't
know if the federal reserve board could
be any worse at their job
frankly and these guys have caused
nothing but booms and busts and
catastrophes
artificial booms and very real busts and
catastrophes my entire lifetime
i mean in the 1980s i'll never forget
that
in northwest austin they had built
entire neighborhoods
and entire shopping malls but it was
just the roads
and the foundations and then it stayed
like that for 10 years
it was another 10 years before they
built lake line mall and we used to just
go out there and
camp and get drunk and skate and skate
dude i love i love it when you find
those like
old slabs yeah just like pre-constructed
buildings that are left for a long time
it's just
and it was just like that playground for
something like 10 years and then we all
lived through
the dot-com massive crash at the end of
the bill clinton years
where instead of cashing our peace
dividend and bringing the troops home
instead they printed a bunch of money
inflated the money supply
see here's the thing about inflation too
is as you say
it's hidden taxation right it's steph
it's the same reason it's against the
law for you and i to counterfeit money
it's because we're stealing the value of
our
neighbors dollars if we do that but
that's not the worst of it
the worst of it is that you get massive
price inflation
in certain sectors like housing
stocks that's happening fuel right now
that's what's happening again right now
yeah
so after the dot-com crash of 2000
they kept inflating housing and they
just poured more and more and more money
into housing to prevent that recession
from really kicking in
and then we had the massive crash of oa
that brought the whole dang world down
with it
then what'd they do qe one two three
four five
and just did nothing but ex expand the
money supply inflate inflate inflate and
just as rothbard teaches
they always try to somehow like prick
the bubble and slowly let the air out
but it's always a crash yep and in fact
though what happened this time was we
were due for a crash last year or this
year
sometime here real soon but what
happened was the governors
donald trump and the governors did it
for us and forced the recession not
through high interest rates
but just by forcing the clampdown the
lockdown on the entire economy
and so that meant all kinds of bad debts
were being canceled off of bank books
right it's massively
deflationary to have in other words it
was
it was a deliberately imposed depression
or recession on the economy
so then where does that leave us right
now with the lockdowns just being lifted
a massive increase in the money supply
that means
we're right back where we were in the
year 2000 2001
right back where we were in the year
2009 just at the start of the next big
bomb so we're good
so we're not on the way that's right we
are yeah unless
you're trying to to afford a place to
live and you can't
and which is why i don't know about
around here but in austin texas there
has
never been a homeless crisis like there
is right now and and in like
it's insane oh it's just unbelievable
and there's people living in tents up
and down the side of the road everywhere
but here's price inflation in housing
and now
and the and the mortgages have gone
through the roof now adam biden
offering up more stimulus and more tax
credits and more money for for not
working
and what's happening we see these
stories where fast food restaurants are
saying you know
500 bonus a thousand dollar bonus come
take the job
and people still won't do it i see from
a lot of leftists they're like oh
surprise surprise nobody wants to work
at fast food unless they're getting paid
a living wage
no dude you're getting paid 16 bucks an
hour to not work
which means i don't got to do anything
why would i take 16
an hour now to work when i'm already get
it to not work well but
plus the cost of living keeps going up
so it's 15 an hour right what it used to
be but this is
this is the problem that's a surface
surface level problem
what people don't see is the same
problems affecting steel mills the same
problem as a stack
is affecting mining raw materials
so while we can laugh that you can't buy
your your popeye's chicken sandwich
because nobody wants to work there
has anyone actually looked at the raw
materials that aren't getting produced
because the same problem is happening or
the farming that's not getting done
because the same problem is happening
you got a farmer and he's like i need
someone to work the fields to to collect
the crops to pick the certain vegetables
and it's like how much you gonna pay i
can pay 20 bucks an hour yeah i get 16
for nothing so no thank you i won't do
it
guess what you go to your store you
can't find bacon anymore you go to a
store you can't find vegetables
it's not just fast food it's hitting
everything and it's been happening since
last year i've mentioned this several
times
i go on amazon i buy a tablet or i put a
tablet in my cart
i forgot i didn't buy it and then a day
or two later i get a notification
the price is increased in this product
one of like 150 bucks
that's how it's it's fast and it's and
you know
we can talk about the fed the printing
and all the stuff but then you have all
this spending
i think we're gonna get hit real bad and
i think bitcoin is gonna through the
roof
by the end of the year don't look at me
i'm not a financial expert i just look
at what max keiser is talking about the
guy's been right
you know a lot so when you combine all
of these things so max keiser comes out
and he's like
bitcoin is going to be his price point
is 220 by the end of the year
maybe not i don't know but i i max has
been right and i've listened to him in
the past i'd be very wealthy
but then i see what he's saying then i
look at the things we're seeing
this fed getting woke thing that
wokeness is not merit which means you're
gonna have people who can't do the job
that's already a ridiculous job the fed
which means potential destabilization on
whatever it is they're trying to do in
the first place is probably gonna get
worse
then you have the mass printing of money
you have no one wanting to work
seems to me like bitcoin's gonna
skyrocket by the end of the year because
the uh
i'm sorry i'm sorry bitcoin's not going
to skyrocket that dollar is going to
collapse yeah that's a better way to put
it huh yeah
i think we need to repeal the federal
reserve act
but we need a new a new system in place
like to withdraw
federal reserve notes and then give you
a cryptocurrency and response
give people two years to turn in all
their federal reserve notes
and then just make them all worth nil
after that so don't hoard your money
turn it in let's start a new economy
obviously they're gonna track it if it's
a
if it's a crypto on the blockchain so
every move you make
i don't know how they'll hide money off
offshore in in panama if it's a crypto
maybe they can't maybe that's the point
or maybe no maybe it's really easy to do
actually
they actually have yeah different kinds
of cryptos too that really do provide
a lot better security i think yeah
monero you can't track uh i think z
cash you can't travel no no zcash can
has has i think i could be wrong about
this but it has
um shadowed shadow accounts and visible
accounts so it works both ways you can
choose to
map like a matched account or none
that's really interesting actually and
look this is what frederick hayek said
was
rather than having i i think murray
rothbard wanted 100
you know by law 100 gold reserve
standard and hayek just said
let there be competing currencies i
think this is the ron paul position
just what you do is you have to repeal
the legal tender laws
and you have to repeal the taxes on
different alternative currencies right
so if you're taxing capital gains on
silver and bitcoins and everything that
makes it impossible to use as a currency
really
or much more especially if you inflate
the dollar
and cause the the cost of silver to go
up
double right and then tax them on that
increase even though the value didn't
increase
they just printed twice the amount of
money so it looks like it and then
you lose a fourth of your money because
they printed twice as much
and they've been printing like crazy i
have to tell you the bad news is
i talked with robert higgs and this
conversation is probably 10 years old
now or more but
robert higgs is the great libertarian
economist that wrote crisis in leviathan
and he's like listen man forget the
petro dollar
forget you know any of the different
kind of answers for
why people are so dependent on the
dollar they're dependent on the dollar
because they have been
the dollar's been the world reserve
currency since the end of world war ii
and it's gonna stay that way for a
very long time because what it would
take
to stop that would be for every central
banker in the world to wake up one day
and realize that all those hundred
dollar bills in their bank vault
are worth nothing and try to panic and
sell them all at the same time
but they're all painted into a corner if
any of them ever do that
then they're the one precipitating the
crisis and making it worse
and they're not going to be able to get
rid of the money before what if they
lose
hold on hold on what if all of these
bankers are sitting there with 100
in their bank account and then they're
like i don't want to be the one to sell
because it'll cost my it'll cause my
money to start losing value
so i won't be able to sell fast enough
and then joe biden yells out turning on
a shop at a pressure and starts printing
money like crazy
then they're gonna be like well he's
already doing it so dump the dollar
right people are going to want to get
out before it hits because he's already
tanking it right it could happen but
then there's also the question of
american military power
and are you going to sell those 100
bills in your vault if we're going to
kill you if you try it wasn't it uh
you know we had gaddafi what did he want
to trade in dinars yeah he wanted to
essentially they still use the french
franc in the formerly french colonies of
africa
yeah and even though the french are on
the euro they still use the french franc
and then he wanted to undermine that by
switching to a gold-backed dinar
yeah although then he died yeah and i'm
not how that happens right i'm not
really sure
like how much evidence there is that
that was really the french's
worry i think sarkozy was really worried
that it was embarrassing
to him that he had stood by um
ben ali in tunisia all the way up until
he was forced to flee
at the at the very start of the arab
spring yeah and so he had a public
relations problem
and he was going to take it out on
gaddafi and then gadhafi had also uh
spent a bunch of money on sarkozy's
election campaign
so then he had the same problem john
mccain and joe lieberman had with
gaddafi was
they had sucked up to him and been too
nice to him recently and so now that he
was a hate figure again they had to turn
on him again well we can
we can thank the obama administration
hillary clinton for absolutely
destroying north africa
absolutely right and look there was just
a piece the other day about the
isis sharia islamist state in northern
mali
which is a direct consequence of the war
in libya it's got a whole chapter in the
book
have you studied uh sydney blumenthal
much uh
she he basically sent emails to hillary
clinton this is part of her email
scandal she tried to delete as much as
possible but you can see in podesta's
you know you can look him up sidney
blumenthal john podesta
i think the blumenthal emails actually
were released by the state department
i think those were not the ones that
were leaked uh in the dnc leak in the
podesta league they were the
they were the state department jason
leopold sued under the freedom of
information act
and they are very incriminating yeah i
mean he warns her that they're rounding
up and murdering blacks just for being
black
on the false accusation that they're
mercenaries and this is in
like april they kept the war going
another eight months after that they
could have called it off at any time
obama
forbade hillary working at all with
cindy blumenthal i thought he was bad
news
and hillary was like okay and then just
kept working with him anyway and he
would send her
battle tactics emails like you need to
invade libya
when we get there we'll set up my
company australia global solutions to
fund the the revolutionaries you know
basically the american-backed new
military
hillary's like okay she just passes it
on to her military that's that's the
game
it's disgusting it's it's called arms
arms running uh war profits hearing it's
illegal
as far as i know although maybe it's not
illegal i don't know
so hold on let's let's let's we'll bring
it back before we go super chats
this is what the woke people realized
there's no truth but power
oh it's illegal well they control the
court so what does it matter anymore
hillary clinton like he like she's gonna
go to jail for anything
well let's let's uh let's jump to super
chats my friends if you haven't already
give that like button a good tap because
it really does help out the show we
appreciate it
and uh thank you to everybody and all
the super chats for your opinions go to
timcast.com become a member because we
have a members only segment
coming up after the show at timcast.com
where we say the things that youtube
doesn't like us saying and we swear a
whole lot
but let's let's uh let's read what we
got here 1976 says for tim and
ian and anyone else that writes songs
what is your process for lyrics
here's what i do i'll make some riffs
i'll jam on the guitar and then
whatever the music sounds like in terms
of feel
i v i envision in my mind
like a world i imagine a scenario
and then i write a story i visualize a
story and then i write the words to
describe
what that story is that's how i do i um
i turn on a video camera
and then i start writing playing chords
together
and then i just start saying whatever
comes out i just start stream of
consciousness riffing
and i'll go back and watch the video and
then write down what i said
and that's usually where the lyrics come
from do you write music
no man i have no musical talent
whatsoever but you can skateboard
i can skateboard right on we're going to
skateboard right after this show we are
you and i we're going to go on the phone
and then we're
want to see you hit up the six foot
that's gonna be fun dude all right
jordan jones says saw your firearm video
righteous bro hear me out
less head movement by bringing the optic
to your eye
and can't your uh your rifle a little
bit you may need to re-zero a bit but
it's good training
right on uh you know we fired a 50 bmg
barrett m82 was a good it was good fun
right yeah we went to the range had a
great time
trent lamolino says scott the man dave
smith for president
oh yeah we didn't talk about dave much
on the show tonight but you want to talk
about dave
is it going to be a smith horton ticket
no it is not
i think but but i will be backing up my
man the whole time i promise that smith
gabbard maybe if tulsi can get involved
tulsi is great i love chelsea
incredible military uh mind she's no
libertarian though no she's i know i
want to bring all these people together
it doesn't matter what party we call it
but i sure would like to see her
run in the primary again yeah that was a
great democrat side
when she just like just mike dropped
and i really think they wanted to be
president oh yeah yeah but
so badly you saw you saw in the polls
like kamal harris and then tulsi gabbard
then
and remember what it was she said she
goes this is a lady who locked people up
by the thousands for
smoking pot and then when she was asked
about it she laughed yep
and this is a lady who hid evidence
that a guy on death row was innocent
and tried to keep him on death row until
finally the courts just intervened why
force her to give up why did she hide it
uh
you know i i have no idea to protect her
underling who had prosecuted the guy i
guess
and then so this is just nothing but
conspiracy to murder somebody right like
how do you recover from that and chelsea
gabbard called her out for it
and she goes yeah you got me i did do
that
called out kamala harris keeping people
in prison beyond their sentences to use
as slave labor to put out fires in
california
that lady is awful and then after the
debate was she just stood there like an
idiot then after the debate was over she
goes
oh yeah well you love bashar al-assad
such tragedy yeah and then the point
went to kamala harris according to tv
oh yeah
adam baker says hey tim took your advice
and started to make good decisions and
work hard
and just got financially stable working
on a stand-up special to send you for
your streaming service keep fighting the
good fight guys
appreciate it man thank you uh i want to
i want to i want to mention something
because there was a a thread
by uh taylor lorenz in the of the new
york times about the housing
boom and she was referencing a tick tock
meme where
they were explaining how housing makes
no sense like so this guy goes
he's like i have an apple i'd like to
sell it and then a guy goes can i see
your apple and he goes no it's an apple
you know what it is taking all bids and
he's like no one's going to want to buy
your apple if you can't and then a guy
goes five dollars
and then some guy goes 20 and then one
guy walks in he's like hundred dollars
i'm from california it's the cheapest
apple i've ever seen it's like a funny
joke right
but so so taylor points out she's like
who has all of this money sitting around
to just buy a house like this
and of course being from new york times
a lot of the responses were from the
traditional establishment left liberal
perspective
where it's like well it's all rich
people and investors who are only able
to buy homes
and you'd get a little bit mixed in
there where someone's like i bought a
home with like only a few percent down
yeah five percent i think
yeah well i mean in some cases even
three percent depending on you know
i think veterans can get zero down but
then my response was
you know i'm not trying to be
disrespectful to any of these people who
who genuinely don't understand
when i got a job at vice and vice was
paying me
decently to be this correspondent
traveling around i stopped i slept on a
couch
for 300 bucks a month i lived in new
york for 300 bucks a month
sleeping on a couch it was not
particularly comfortable
people would be coming over and my
friend was doing his thing and i'd wake
up at three in the morning
and like again migraines but 300 bucks
can't be beaten williamsburg
and so then all the money advice was
paying me i just go into the bank going
to the bank
and then you don't need that much to
actually buy a house like
several thousand dollars like i think
it's like five like uh 5k and closing
costs depending on what percentage
you're putting down
you can get a house young people don't
realize this i've met too many people
who are like
my apartment costs three grand i'm like
have you considered like
not having a three thousand dollar
apartment i guess
people don't they can't fathom sleeping
on a floor
for for for dirt to save money they
can't have them sacrificing
they believe that they should have a a
certain standard and i can respect it
people should have a house and like a
bed and like a shower and stuff
but life isn't this like video game
where the rules are equal for everybody
you know life is it is what it is some
people live outside
some people are happy living outside
some people have
parents who pay their bills and if you
want to get ahead that means you got to
save resources but
just wanted to say that let's read some
more ameris 45 says u.s expat in china
this video made the rounds on wechat any
comments were shut down quick
people are terrified to say anything
about it here cherish and protect free
speech i miss it
first super chat hey appreciate it what
video this video
no the john cena one oh yeah we got a
bunch of uh
uh super chats in china joel stein says
normalizing relations with china didn't
make them more
like us it's making us more like them
raise that red fist
i mean that's another thing like you
know the black lives matter symbol is
the red salute
yeah and people like i see people in my
understanding family marching around
raising the red salute i'm like that's
that's that's scary that's creepy
ideological stuff
which you know when you mentioned
earlier about how the idea was
we sent milton friedman over there to
teach xiaoping about capitalism that
they'll end up
adopting a more of a libertarian social
policy as well
and you know it's easy to just say well
that didn't come true
but i always like to start with my blame
in washington dc
and it seems to me like if at the end of
the cold war we'd elected
ron paul in 88 when he ran and we'd
elected harry brown in 96 to see us
through
the end of the 20th century and into the
21st and we had renounced world empire
and harry brown just spent every day
giving the world his statue of liberty
speech
not killing them but constantly
lecturing them
on not being free enough and not doing
enough to protect human liberty
and i think we'd be living in an
entirely different world in the muslim
world
and in china and everywhere else i think
the
the true american creed of individualism
and liberty out of our declaration of
independence
would have a lot more purchase but
instead america
is the most corrupt government on the
face of the earth
it's soaking in the blood of something
like two million
dead people from the last 20 years and
for nothing
attacking countries that never attacked
and never attacked us
never threatened us so if you look at
places like
say pakistan where they'll stone you to
death for converting to christianity
well we're not really in any position to
criticize them for that because you know
what's the worst thing about pakistan
american drones blowing grandmothers up
okay and so how can we say to them you
guys aren't doing liberty right
when we're not doing liberty right and
we're supposed to be the standard bears
do you know what the mandela effect is
yeah yeah you know the mandela yeah
that's right so there so for those that
aren't familiar it's that it started
because
some people were convinced that they
heard news reports that nelson mandela
died in prison
yet he didn't and then he was alive and
so people are like what is this
and so a lot of people then believe that
they've accidentally jumped timelines
can we just um you know everybody right
now just wish
wish it's possible so we can jump in the
timeline where ron paul won
in 2008 oh and how about in 88
in 88 to oversee the end of the cold war
well
the problem is the timelines are too
divergent at that point maybe maybe 10
years as a leap
you know what though one of the ones
that really solidified that whole
theory the mandela thing i remember
listening to this on our bell driving my
cab around
and they were like yeah you know what
also i remember the soviets went to the
moon
i know they did i remember that and i
know where that came from that's not an
alternative dimension
that's from superman too where they're
on the moon at the beginning and they
got a russian
and that's that's where that's really
what it likely is but i want to point
out something that's very
look i remember the ron paul era and
i didn't agree with a lot of his like
moral positions
but i did agree with him saying no and
leave me alone and leave it leave
everyone to their own devices and i was
like
i'll take the guy who's gonna leave me
alone because we can disagree on
everything but then he agrees to leave
me alone right that's great
dude we should jump to the timeline when
george washington became the first
american president
what because ben franklin did not he
dropped the ball
wait what george washington president i
think this guy's from another dimension
yeah we all think that anyway i think we
should jump to that timeline all right
all right let's read some more
uh says god damn it 2am here in sweden i
see that the legend scott horton is on
with tim
i recently got my copy of enough already
you guys are the best yeah i got mine as
well
but mine's autographed oh yeah everybody
show the book to the camera yeah
again at the end of the show that's
right yes that's every war from jimmy
carter through
the end of donald trump is it possible
to end war you think and just live in
like a
harmonious symbiosis mostly
like in terms of like a magical utopia
where it never breaks out ever again
kind of thing no but
at the same time um
there are many nations in the world that
just
never even entertain the idea of going
to war with each other you know look at
all the latin america
costa rica's abolish their entire
military yeah they're not afraid of
being invaded
by honduras honduras isn't going to
invade them and they just
take it easy um it's improved a lot of
like literacy rates and things like that
they've invested in education
yeah you know there was an article in
the washington post
that said war is good for the economy
and war is great and all this
it was obviously a completely amoral
take
but what he was saying what had some
truth to it in the sense that he was
arguing that the larger the conquest
the more peace and security within that
conquest
the better it is for that population so
for example there hasn't been a major
outbreak of war
between canada in the space between
canada and mexico since the 1860s
and we've had this you know largely
territorial monopoly on violence
and they finished killing off all the
indians after the end of the civil war
but once they finish with the indian
wars we have essentially
had peace and stability through this
entire continent
that was won through warfare so and that
this has really been good for the
american people
overall in a moral sense at least just
in a financial sense and
in the growth of american power but the
thing of it is where he the guy that
wrote the article where he's
making the the invigious conflation
is he's comparing the size of the
territory
controlled by any given government with
the size of the government
and having a giant war and having a
massive government that has this total
control
when in fact you could have an extremely
minimal federal government in washington
dc
say for example just enough to keep the
peace between texas and louisiana
but nothing more than that then that
would really be
you know all other things being equal
that would be the ideal
we we can end war it's very easy and i
have this idea
i was thinking that what we would need
to do is you know
at the height of these tensions around
the world you know the russia the north
korea the china stuff
we need to generate a fake
alien invasion that unifies all the
countries against it now the biggest
problem we're facing is that dr
manhattan can see into the future
so we'll need to do some tachyon
research to cloud his vision in which
case then we'll actually be able to get
away with it solve the dr manhattan
problem
right all right so as soon as we solve
that we'll be able to stage the alien
invasion which will unify the planet
you know what we can do with north korea
here's what we could do with north korea
we could kill them with kindness
we could drop all sanctions we could
promise to
negotiate a final peace deal to end the
korean war which we have only a
ceasefire left over from 1952
we could open up all trade relations
with them
we could send dennis rodman and all of
his friends
and and all of our best and worst bands
and whatever and
and just we have absolutely nothing to
lose i think everything
together flies with honey let me let me
read this though dylan keller says
stop bringing ccp shills on the show
lmao
although i guess it works out for you
since it gets dummies like me to super
chat
you you're on to us no we we bring
people on the show
we i mean i'd love to have a bunch of
socialists on the show they don't want
to do it they're scared
they're genuinely afraid of two things
one legit
leftists are scared of covet like young
20-something leftists we've invited on
the show are like dude
i'm really terrified i won't i won't
travel and i'm like okay and we've had a
few that are like i'm not worried about
it
so they're scared of that but many of
them are scared of getting cancelled
they there's there's a few people i know
they do not have
look a lot of these leftists are young
you know you got 10 years on me you know
so much more than i do about this
foreign policy stuff i'm not afraid to
be like oh
you know i guess i don't know that huh
that's interesting but they are
they know if they come on this show and
they're like 25 i'm 35
i don't know everything but i have 10
years more experience watching all this
political stuff
they'll get trounced they'll say
something about like some socialist
policy and then i'll bring up something
where like it happened it didn't work
and they'll be like i don't know what
that is
so they don't want to come on the show
i'd love to have conflicting opinions uh
we try to get as many
people with different opinions as
possible so but uh it is true that
whenever there's
disagreeableness or you know passion
people super chat a lot more yeah sure
which by the way the government of china
i don't think anybody argues whether
it's a totalitarian dictatorship or
whether the people there are free or not
the question is whether we should fight
them or not right the question is
whether we should believe all the
propaganda that's told about them in
order to try to get us amped up to fight
the question is whether they pose a
threat to the people the united states
of america
or don't they and what should our real
policy be all right
well let's read that we got more we got
the uh brock wick says get michael
bolden from 10th amendment center on the
show
oh yeah he is an expert on states
nullifying federal law regarding guns
weed and immigration sanctuaries
absolutely endorse that let me tell you
something michael bolden is a
brilliant genius and the 10th amendment
center does such good work and because
they're libertarians
they you know they they tell leftists oh
you don't like nullification because
that reminds you of
the civil war or something like that
well what do you think
sanctuary cities for immigrants are yeah
and what do you think legalized pot is
that's nullification and interposition
straight out of the virginia and
kentucky resolutions
and then he says to the right wingers he
goes listen
you guys might not like sanctuary cities
and legalize pot
but it's working so do it what you need
to do with guns
how are you going to stop there gun
control they're doing it you do it from
the bottom up
nullification declaring sanctuary states
what happens if you know i think west
virginia declared a sanctuary to a
sanctuary
i think that i'm not sure but what
happens if one of these jurisdictions
everybody just says they're gonna
buy up nfa items the atf doesn't have
the ability to go after that
so prohibition doesn't work the federal
government is not that strong it's only
through confidence
in their power that people you know
abide by this stuff right that being
said
becomes a really interesting point for
how youtube would function
if west virginia says it's legal the
federal government says it isn't
what do you who who's the right in that
regard because the states are sovereign
you know the federal government is it's
a federation there it's it does
you know it is supposed to supersede but
then is california wrong can we can we
say california's wrong about immigration
rights western what's wrong about guns
what do they they have the supremacy
clause but that doesn't mean that
unconstitutional federal laws override
state laws only constitutional ones and
so
now the courts are always going to
almost always side with the feds
right but if you remember back in the
1990s um
there's this guy sheriff mack sued under
the 10th amendment
against the it wasn't the second
amendment he used the 10th amendment
to sue over the background checks
because it was essentially an
unfunded federal mandate to the states
that they had to do these background
checks and pay for them all
and he said this is a violation of the
10th amendment and the supreme court
upheld it and
struck down the background checks on
that all right let's uh let's read a
little bit more we got
daniel maxwell says china is fighting an
economic war against the united states
while trying also
to keep the united states ignorant of
that fact
i think so oh what does economic war
mean they keep selling us microphones at
reasonable prices
it means that they can have their p
their people work in unsavory
circumstances
with the point of mass suicide to
undercut the market making it cheaper
and more lucrative for
american greedy interests to just send
the factories overseas the expense of
the american worker that sounds like a
war
between american big business and
american workers and the chinese are
just
the useful tool of the americans well
the the the chinese view it as
you know we're in the we're in this for
the long haul let's extract as much
value from that system and
and enrich ourselves and it means to
them make the people
essentially sacrifice and that's
long-term planning in the u.s you get
some ceos who's like
i can make more money moving the the
factory over to china so i'll do it
and it's terrible for the environment so
that's the economic warfare it's also
the belt and road initiative it's also
the attempts
you know i'm for that i don't see what's
the problem with the belt and road
initiative they want to build a highway
and a railroad line and a fiber optic
line from shanghai to lisbon
that's it's it's it's all the greatest
invention in human history what's wrong
with that it's just all part of economic
warfare i'm not
i think it's just see the warfare part
of it economics you know capitalism
is mutually beneficial exchange i mean
you're right that they have a government
and everything but what threat do they
pose for example this is part of my
whole authoritarianism encroaching
throughout the
the world yeah but look kazakhstan is
already an authoritarian state the
chinese aren't making it into one
you know what i mean um and you know
people
talk about we have to stay in
afghanistan to keep china out
but china's not invading afghanistan if
they buy it
yeah if they're going to buy anything
they're going to try to buy
you know influence in very small areas
where they can make some money mining or
something but there's no real security
let's let's get more serious though do
you know that one of the reasons we have
a housing crisis that china will come in
and offer insane amounts of money to
people selling
so somebody's got a house it's worth
300k they'll be like i'm going to sell
for 300 and then a working-class family
says i can afford that and then china's
investors says i'll give you 400 on the
spot
working-class family can't get the house
then you end up with more homeless i'd
like to know more about the chinese role
in inflating
the american housing prices i mean right
now in austin where i'm from
you have hundreds and hundreds thousands
even of houses being bought up at a time
by wall street hedge funds
and they're not chinese they're from new
york
and the thing is the interest rates are
so low
they actually would be crazy to not do
that they actually you know seem to have
no choice
but to invest in land because nothing
else is paying off
and so you know you can't invest in a
bank cd right you can't just have a
savings account you got to
do something with your money you got
little old ladies gambling and bitcoins
in the stock market because
they're losing money on having a savings
account so you have
and then they all you know invest in
these mutual funds
and these kinds of things and they turn
around and and buy up all the housing
but again it all comes from the free
money the hedge funds where the where
the hedge funds getting this money
that's not their savings
they're taking out a giant loan from the
bank that got it from the fed gave them
a license to print money yeah all right
let's read this we've got sergeant hotel
says
hey tim let's all help out project
veritas for free
shockingly the woke amazon smile program
has veritas available as a charitable
organization
and a portion of all your purchases get
donated to them cool
absolutely yeah yeah veritas posted the
clip from the show where i said james
needs
he needs to get corrective surgery
because for his back because he has too
many spines or
his spine is too big that was funny i
thought it was funny that's hilarious
i said it and then i heard it and i was
like i'm funny i'm a funny guy
it was a good show it's good to
appreciate yourself
all right the civic nationalist says
scott and everyone go watch
tik on youtube he has a lot of videos on
the second world war
hitler was the aggressor we were
defending the polish from both the
soviets and the germans
also look into pax britannica don't talk
about things you know so little about
read churchill hitler and the
unnecessary war by pat buchanan we
weren't defending poland from anything
poland belonged to the communists until
1989
the british never put one soldier on the
ground in poland
to kick the nazis out the whole thing
was a giant blunder and
it was winston churchill himself who
said at the end of the war
ah jeez i guess i really shouldn't have
done that huh
yeah i got one you'll like free men die
free says conservatives have always been
wrong on foreign policy
it's the libertarian's turn to control
foreign policy full autos for all the
citizens and death to the military
empire
uh i'm i'm totally down you know you
know why i've always said like
my politics are actually like kind of
left of center libertarian but i would
vote for like among candidates like a
ron paul i think it was ron paul who
said
no one is stopping a paraphrase if you
want to have a socialist
commune in the united states no one's
stopping you right you literally can
just go do it and i'm like i dig it
so if that guy's in charge you can leave
me alone and i'll do and i'll live the
way i want to i don't i'm libertarian i
don't want to tell anybody i might lean
left because that means
i want to have a farm with a bunch of
hippies on it we share their watermelons
and we don't want to compete but if you
want to have an an and cap or a more
libertarian right thing
you go do your thing i'll do my thing
that's what we all agree on ron paul was
a candidate for that
i'll take it you know you know in austin
when i grew up there was a
hippie commune out east of town out in
bastrop called the zendik farm
and they had a mini ramp out there so me
and my friend john went out to skate the
mini ramp
that's probably the last time i could do
ollie balloons
and uh those are the days and it was
crazy like
you know they had it was just like you
would expect right there's the big
purple house where only the elite of the
commune are allowed to go
right and then you have the smaller
house where the other guy and then you
know there's people out there breaking
their back in the field and
it didn't seem very fun to me at all
yeah it was ridiculous man
yeah that's that's a thing but they were
free to do it and nobody stopped them
from doing it communism
is the most effective form of government
for five people yeah i deposited about
the system for the dictator yeah
no no no no no no no uh in in every
scale
so if you're just five people like it's
just you and four other people
communism works real great like the who
who said it where murphy jack murphy at
home i'm a communist he was quoting
someone else you know we we all share
all the resources for everybody
the kids do the chores because what
they're able to do but they get food
regardless
and yes when you're just five people
it's very very easy to have friends who
work together
and said you know he's i am gonna go do
the dishes would you mind picking up the
food yeah no problem it's simple
and then as you scale up communism works
really well for five people
once you have a country of 300 million
communism still works really well for
just those five people
yeah that's that's the name of the game
all right all right uh creamer of the
dairy squad says
sixth super chat hope you read it hey
tim got my emergency food in the mail
today
ian check your twitter dms message about
metaphysics
i like that oh we got some um
polycarbonate should have been here
today for three
3d printing yep oh it's cool it is here
yeah i thought did andreas get it
uh i put it outside i hope you found it
it's sitting on the
it's sitting so i printed a uh this is
this is one of the coolest things ever
i've been rollerblading a lot more than
skateboarding and we've been having fun
with it
but there's a thing called an h block
which allows you to do grinds on
rollerblades we 3d printed our own
and i shattered chatted oh nice it's
awesome
but it was just really cool to be able
to 3d print something i could
practically use that that works
and then to break it was even better so
i was like yeah because i printed
another one
3d printings did you document it yet no
no it just broke and then i popped it
out and then i worked
so hopefully we'll put 3d print on
polycarbonate oh that'd be a good video
we should
yeah we should vlog that yeah and it's
really cool um i also ordered these
ridiculous
roller blades they're not rollerblades
they're uh uh
two bike tires and then on the axle on
the inside
are foot holders what so you actually
strap your feet in and you have two bike
tires on your left and right legs
it's the craziest looking thing ever
it's gonna be so much fun and they have
inner tubes
they're like actual bike tires we're
gonna get weird oh cool and i'll be the
i'll be the only one to actually do
tricks on those things and people will
be
like it's a new sport and then we got to
get pogo sticks
yeah dude i've seen some amazing pogo
stick videos i've seen like people do
grinds on these like
a guy hit a handle on a pogo stick they
do it all the time yeah i saw some
insane pogo stick video about a year ago
it was and it was it was the pogo stick
itself was like a new and improved
kind of version and then like you're
saying yeah yeah doing stairs and rails
that's cool man i like the guy he like
pogoed up did like a
pogo spin and then land on a handrail
that's fun stuff man
i'm stoked to see that i just it's just
really cool to see people use things in
ways they weren't intended
i i've always been a hacker and that's
the thing about hacking hacking is
making something do something it wasn't
intended to do
skateboarding and all of these
disciplines do very much of that it's
awesome i love it yep
all right let's grab some more super
chats here oh that one got retracted
we don't have too much time but we'll as
many as we can
i am insanity says been watching since
2015 and modeled my news channel after
you
no cursing and article fact based would
love a shout out for both this channel
let's play slash video games and the n
sane report that's e-n-s-a-n-e
news with a psychotic twist hey there
you go man appreciate it
good luck cool soul invictus says my
local news channel
could not report on overnight shootings
without saying in such a way that it
made it sound like a 17 year old shot a
90 year old in reality
they were two separate victims weird
yeah today at george floyd
square the no-go zone there was a act
like the news reporter was giving his
speech or whatever and then gunshots
started ringing out like crazy hitting
the ground
yeah and you know what i said i'm
looking at the story and i'm like that's
a no-go zone
the no-go zones are defined as areas
where normal government governance
governance has ceased the police medical
can't go there or are
are scared to go there regular people
can't enter or
can enter with only great risk and i'm
like that clearly defines all of these
autonomous zones
there's like people being shot and
killed and
the the people who have written about
the george floyd square it's not some
like anarchist utopia it is it is
violence and chaos it is the opposite of
what people you know
it's it's the opposite of what we hear
about like uh um was it
uh acapulco how do you is that is that
it yeah and archipelago anarchopolis
that's the that's the event
yeah yeah down there i hear like people
get along and actually what's that
what's that place in mexico where they
got rid of the police i don't know but i
know what you're talking about see
that's that's in the west i think right
the places like that are where like
actual anarchy
functions when regular people just want
to be left alone these autonomous zones
are being run by authoritarians
who just do whatever they want it's just
absolutely not the same thing
oh yeah yep
sonny james says disagree with your
guest's opinion on azt
it was recycled on aids patients when
doctors found it too deadly for cancer
patients
fauci made money off of that not to
mention kerry mullis said
pcr technology couldn't detect viruses
he wanted to debate fauci
interesting all right i missed uh mixed
up azt with another one then or
something because i know that
the story in the 80s was he was
suppressing the drugs
in order to boost research into the
vaccine
interesting all right they never did
come up with that we have carrie mullis
is legit by the way i like that guy a
lot
yeah yeah stephen clyde says scott i had
a blast hanging out with you at the lp
convention
can you talk about the mises caucus for
a minute
yeah sure so the mises caucus is a
radical new young faction of the
libertarian party led by a guy named
michael heiss
and it's basically the ron paul
revolution has decided to join the lp
see there's been a real problem with the
libertarian party because back in the
1980s
the rothbard faction and the cato
faction all fought so badly
they both left and they essentially just
left kind of a husk
of an lp behind and there's been
no offense to long-term lp people out
there i'm not trying to fight you but
there's been this dichotomy where you
have the people who sit around reading
and caring about this stuff
and then you have the people who work
together in the party networking and
doing the work and collecting the
petitions and staying on the ballot and
things
but those people don't read and don't
know what the hell is going on and
they're not mad as hell about it and so
you get a lot of stuff like geez it'd be
better if taxes were lower and
you know wars are bad but you don't get
like hey man
these taxes are destroying these
people's lives
and this war is bad and this war is bad
and this war is bad
now now hear me out though but this is
the this is the new invention is the
mises caucus are guys who are principled
and radical
and actually care a lot about what's
going on in the country now
so they could talk about libertarianism
in a way that's not just abstraction
like hey we should be like switzerland
neutral but we need to come home from
afghanistan today
now hear me out okay what if we raised
taxes to 100
and engaged in complete and total war
around the planet oh
well that's what it would take probably
and then we'd all lose the opposite yeah
we'd all lose because there's what eight
or nine countries with h-bombs now
so all right uh what is this garbage
main
tim please tell scott hi from his
favorite garbage man and skateboarder in
san antonio can't wait to skate that
ramp again
soon oh yeah this is my guy we're
twitter friends and now he's coming out
to the vert ramp we skate every
wednesday
and uh sunday morning right now skate
church and he's going to get them
all right here soon danger close uh says
ask this guy if it's moral to position
rocket artillery next to schools and
hospitals
hamas uses the palestinian people as
meat shields ask him if he supports the
chant from the river to the sea
palestinian palestine will be free
hilarious should israel turn off the
iron dome and roll over
first ask him if if it's a war crime for
the israelis to put their defense
department right in the middle of
downtown tel aviv
because that's the exact same thing the
gaza strip is one of the most heavily
populated places in the world it's a
concentration camp
okay now people talk about well what
would you do if the mexicans
started firing rockets over the rio
grande well by that you mean
the mexican military the mexicans not
some mexicans
the mexicans means the sovereign nation
state of mexico and its military
but that's not what's going on here
these people were conquered
54 years ago they live in a
concentration camp under the
total and complete control of israel so
so it's not a sovereign state with hamas
attacking and starting a war and the
israelis defending themselves that's not
it at all
and there's essentially very few places
in the gaza strip
you could place artillery or rockets or
anything
where it's not close to somebody else
now you want to talk about human shields
just type in israeli soldiers human
shields and there they tie a little kid
to the uh to the uh or no they tied a
grown man to the
uh front of their jeep and drove around
with him in 2014 use him as a
human shield and then there's a picture
of a little boy probably 13 14 years old
who for hours they made the idf made him
walk in front of them
and and go in first when they kicked
indoors and all these things
literally using him as a human shield
not a figure of speech
a metaphor well hamas launches rockets
from
nearby i don't even know if it's
civilians to launch the rock
and islam i'm getting i'm getting so
this is so i don't know what's that i
don't know if it's a false flag
okay okay it is true that hamas was
operating in the same building as the
associated press
no that's not true there's no report for
that it was reported in 2014 that
reporters for this is depressed yeah but
that reporter was full of it and the
associated press
repudiated his claims then there was no
evidence for that whatsoever it was a
total hoax
i can't fake news so this is this is the
inherent challenge
based on reports so here's what we have
we have the israelis claimed that
and you have the israelis told joe biden
here's the evidence for it
and joe biden accepted it but it's still
secret they've never provided any
evidence this is this and the ap
said that's absolutely not the case but
this is the problem with
this conflict period is that
it is it is it is the it is one of like
the issues
you you have to choose who you trust
choose if it's fake news or not i don't
trust
any millionaires organization it's just
like anything else though i mean what it
is
is choose as many different sources of
information as you can
and then make them fight right you can't
live your life without reading the
washington post you have to read the
washington post
you also have to know that they are your
enemy and they hate your guts and they
lie to you most of the time
and they have an agenda at the same time
they have real resources
and important reporters they get
important stories so you have the same
problem
sift and sift and sift it it's your best
it's the same problem
when i see videos in new york of a
palestinian activist chasing a jewish
man down the street
or or a juice guy getting getting beaten
attacked or a woman getting explosive
thrown at her by these pro-palestinian
groups
and then i see them telling me that
they're defending themselves
so i understand that's not the same
thing as palestine but i see these
videos coming out of activist groups
that are very much i i enter this thing
as like
i was not alive when this thing started
and i see videos where i'm like they're
both claiming the same things about each
other
which one am i supposed to just decide
is correct or right right or wrong hey i
got another better idea
why the [ __ ] are we involved in it right
now you got me swearing there we go
let's it's already yeah i know we're
gonna get to the after show so let me
let me uh we'll read some some more
super chats but we got we'll do we'll do
one last one which is a big one
mark ashley says hey scott what's your
theory on why abdulrahman al-awlaki was
killed
uh i think it was just because of
what a propagandist he was what a
successful propagandist he was this is
before youtube was kicking people off
oh i'm sorry the boy i'm sorry um
not anwar i i think only because he knew
too much
i mean they said that they were trying
to kill the guy he was with
and that he was you know unlucky to be
there too
they bombed him in yemen well
they don't care about that right but i
think i mean if there was
like a a kind of covert sort of secret
reason why they wanted to kill the boy
it was because he knew too much about
his father
because he was certainly not a terrorist
he went there to find his father and
bring him home
and but he had to have known that he had
been an fbi
informant in the past and things like
that
i mean honestly the occam's razor
explanation is they just didn't give a
damn they were killing the guy that he
was with
and he was there now what's interesting
really interesting is
the i forget if it was delta the seals i
think it was the seals
shot and killed awlaki's daughter that's
right
under trump under trump shot her in the
neck she bled out over
four hours and yeah eight years old and
uh or nine i think eight yeah yeah
um and and again they said well
wrong place wrong time she was at uh you
know associated with this guy who
yep for for obvious reasons had been
associated with her father
and and that's an american citizen who
was killed without charge or trump all
three of them all three of them
american-born american citizens
and that was uh obama granted us that
but that that eight-year-old girl was
under donald trump that was one of his
first orders so
but uh man what an awful note to leave
the show on huh
well we're gonna go to timcast.com and
have a bonus segment so make sure you go
and sign up
follow this show on facebook
facebook.comcast.irl share our videos
so we can leverage that network get more
people to come to the website and we're
on instagram at tim cast irl we're live
monday through friday at 8 pm so thanks
for hanging out leave us a good review
on all the podcasts if you uh
you know review platforms whatever do
you want to shout anything out
scott antiwar.com antiwar.com is the
most important project
on the internet and uh i'm pretty proud
of the libertarian institute as well
and uh check out the book enough already
it's all the wars from jimmy carter
through right now
and sign up for my podcast feed i'm at
scotthorne.org i
actually have 5 500 something interviews
for you going back to o3 there
almost all on foreign policy and i'm
also on youtube.com
scotthorton show oh and one more thing
about that if you go to youtube.com
scotthorton show i have the video
version of that book
where i basically walk through all of it
from jimmy carter all the way through
and that's kind of a nice little primer
to get you started cool
uh you can follow me at iancrossland.net
and at ian crosston on social media this
is it enough already time to end the war
on terrorism by scott horton and scott
where's the best place people can get
this
uh it's on amazon but also if you go to
uh
libertarian institute.org enough already
we got links to all of the different
places barnes and noble and powell's
books and
smash words and you can even read it on
scribd
and all of those things got all those
options for you
you guys are free to follow me on
twitter.com at sourpatchlist as i
attempt to get more followers since our
patch kids oh yeah i'm
at scotthorne's show on twitter too
there you go we will see you all over at
timcast.com in the exclusive
members only segment thanks for hanging
out we'll see you there
you